You know,
are we live yet?
Right now alive,
which probably costs a shitload of
money.
We're trying to figure like riders on
the storm.
Doon Doon Doon Doon I think that would
be the best way to open a pod podcast
ever too much though,
right?
I'll talk to some people think Wheeler
Walker.
June.
Yeah.
Oh,
on camera.
We're on camera with the whole deal.
You look fucking fantastic.
Uh,
I found out about you through our mutual
friend who turned me on to eat and pussy
and kicking ass and I was a fan right
away.
Instantly.
We're on this trail.
This is 100% legit.
Yeah.
I love the show.
And we,
uh,
I'm out here a fucking,
I'm not making this up.
We bought tickets for this weekend
because we were going to do
a coachella too gay.
They set,
the goal was we were going to do it and
they said it was too fucking x ray to,
we can't focus,
which was fucking bullshit to me,
man.
You're too risque for Coachella.
Coachella is all about taking ecstasy as
well.
I fucking thought,
you know,
it's just,
I dunno.
Maybe that's their excuse that you just
don't want me,
you know,
it could have been the nice way of
saying let's just go over the playlist
and perhaps we'll see where the hitch
is.
My baby,
I think I may be with them and then you
redneck shit.
I don't have any problem with that.
That's his name of the album.
That's easy.
We're banned from Walmart by the way.
That's,
that's applause beer.
We'd coaches.
That's fine.
Family tree.
Totally fine.
That's the dirties one though.
Oh really?
Can't fuck you off my mind.
So you start getting a little edgy.
Fuck you bitch ballad.
Drop them out.
That's easy.
Eating Pussy,
kicking ass.
My favorite fight and fucking farden.
That's fine.
Better off,
beaten off.
Sit on my face.
And then the Coupe de Gras.
Which one are you?
Queer.
It's going to suck my Dick and man,
shit happens.
You get book Yo black out and go to head
to a bar.
Well the problem is the titles are
actually wakeling up the salt.
I mean,
I go,
no,
here's the
see what happens.
So I went to my buddy,
Dave cobb,
he's a producer there.
I actually met him through your buddy
sturgeon.
Actually,
I didn't really meet him,
but everyone,
there's a bunch of articles that said
stars will introduce me to him.
So I'm just going with it.
Well it means we're in narrative.
I'd help.
But um,
so,
uh,
and I'd kind of been kicking around
Nashville for like about 15 years or so
and with no success at all.
I mean just bullshit.
And I'd been,
had my ass kicked my dick in the dirt as
they say.
And then,
um,
you know,
I was like,
fuck it,
this is going to be my last record.
I was like,
I'm going to whatever they call it,
drop the mike put out a really fucking
dirty ass record though at record.
I was wanting to make and not pull any
punches.
I was going to just pay for my cell
phone and myself and I have a feeling
this was going to get me banned from
Nashville.
And then I just leave cause I fucking
broke.
So we made this fucking dirty record and
it's probably about as dirt and it's
not,
it wasn't even like I want to make the
dirties country record.
It was just like,
what's happened now in Nashville cause
it's turned into such fucking bullshit
is um,
well money's happened,
right?
Well what's happened is country radio is
no longer country music.
What is it?
It's,
and I didn't know this any more new
cause I don't listen to that dog shit,
but I um,
I actually heard the best explanation
for it the other day.
Steve Earle,
who's a hero of mine,
he was on this Chris Shifflet podcast.
I don't know if you know,
he is,
if he's a guitar player for foo fighters
is a good podcast where he interviews a
lot of country music.
He loves country.
Oh Wow.
And Steve Earle goes,
um,
you could say,
you could hear him.
He's kind of talking around it.
He goes
country today,
you know,
mainstream corporate country is,
he goes,
it's rap music for people.
And he pauses,
he's like,
it's rap music for people.
And he just,
you keep hearing him pause.
Like is he going to say it?
He goes,
it's rep people for it's rap music for
people who are scared of black people.
And he's not saying as a joke,
but I started listening.
He's absolutely fucking 100% right.
It's Luke Bryan.
Do like a duet with a rapper nail do
that if you want.
It is,
it's like beats and you know,
you said you don't some hip hop and she
is,
this is Jamie's big on the hip hop.
Yeah.
You like it's beats from,
but the thing is,
here's my thing.
If you were making
good sounding like it's beats from the
eighties really soft guy with the
baseball hat,
he's thinking about trucks and beers and
dog shit like that.
It's the worst fucking go to the river.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No,
it's just so,
and have you seen that compilation?
What's it is a compilation.
They put it all these different
musicians singing the exact same thing.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Well have,
see,
I've heard a lot of this one compilation
of country artists.
It's just the same song.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
That calculation.
They're all talking about being by the
river,
you're tight blue jeans.
Like there's all these like different
things that they just repeat.
I me,
it's fuck,
it's disgusting.
Rarely is what it is.
Another thing too is
I listened to Nwa,
I listen to public enemy.
I listened to,
you know,
get a boy.
It's like I don't need to hear white boy
wrap.
I'll listen.
If I want us to know alison,
all kinds of music,
I want listen to wrap all this into
fucking rat,
right?
So I went in the studio,
I'm like,
I want to make some real fucking country
music.
And at the time I didn't know what had
happened.
And you know,
I'm in Nashville,
but I'm in my house.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
So I,
um,
whenever I write a song,
like my first instinct is just not to
censor it,
you know,
why would you and I started playing in
the studio and they're like,
this guy motherfucks going,
I mean,
I'm fist in the chicks and going know
guys blowing each other and uncles,
you know,
implicitly and kicking ass had me
literally like cry and laugh.
Well that's one of those,
that's probably the cleanest song.
It's a funny song though.
Funny,
we were listening to playback and I go,
we listen to fuck you bitch.
Which is the,
I was gonna say the head that's the hit,
if you can call it a hip.
Let me a second to realize that was also
you,
because I saw the first one,
uh,
from,
the Ben Hoffman show.
Yeah.
Fuck that dude.
If you don't Ben Hoffman.
No,
he talked me into doing his fucking,
uh,
is uh,
he had a show on comedy central as the
saying goes,
I was sick that week,
so I didn't get to see it as just
fucking canceled.
It wasn't funny.
And He,
the dude just came off like kind of like
a cock sucker.
Wow.
And a strong word.
I don't want us to be brothers.
He looked exactly like,
he looked like real similar.
I don't think so.
But whatever,
you know each man,
each,
each to his own dude.
I'm half blind.
Okay,
well that's cool.
I was going to say I don't,
I mean I wear glasses now.
Um,
so I did that thing and then you know,
I think that's where maybe cobb or you
know,
cause I knew sturge we'll back in
Kentucky.
Anyway,
the point I'm trying,
I'm all over the place.
I started getting around.
What was interesting to me was I started
getting around through,
no,
like big promotion.
Just people passing it on.
Someone would find out about it.
They'd send it to this guy and he would
send it to his friends and that's how I
got it.
Well that's,
it might've been stirred all the sound
to me.
It's very pop.
Cause every,
what had happened,
what happened was,
and kind of the main point was I was in
the studio back to what we were talking
about and I'm listening to playback to
fuck fuck you bitch.
And I go,
man,
this is so pretty.
If I made it clean,
you know,
like love you girl,
whatever.
I go,
this could get played on the radio.
And they look at me like I'm crazy and
they go,
this ain't getting played on the radio.
I go,
why not?
They go cause it's real country music
and they don't play that on the radio
anymore.
Then I go,
if it's just,
if I can get in and get banned for
playing real country,
why not just fucking not censor myself
at all and do it fucking X.
Right.
So that,
that's what kind of convinced me just to
do it my fucking way.
You know.
So as someone who is a country music
artist and is a fan of country music,
and we talked about country music before
the show started,
there's,
you've got to be some hope that this
guy's like shooter jennings and
sturgeon.
There's an these new guys that are
coming up that are really fucking
talented.
That's the only hope.
I mean really what's happened.
Here's my thing and I've gotten a lot of
fuck,
I mean all the kind of mainstream,
it's not fucking around.
I mean like music growing happy that my
out,
it was grammy week when my album came
out like eight weeks ago and I out,
my album debuted at number nine on the
billboard country charts during gray
areas outsold people who are on the
fucking grammys and I'm just,
that's from a fucking few tweet and I
ain't got no twitter followers if I
don't even know how to use it.
Facebook and you know I sign up for
snapchat hoping to get a bunch of tea
cause they said that's where the tits
come in.
Snapchat's got,
I've gotten about the office.
Snapchat.
Jamie gotten 25,000 ticks.
I got nothing but Dixon and I've gotten
like four.
The nasties ticks you've ever seen.
Well men are disgusting.
So men take chances on guys,
a gay guy and you've got all these songs
about gay guys sucking Dick.
So like I can get this guy well that,
well,
the the thing they're not even doing,
these aren't gay guys.
These are guys who are just like,
I love your album.
I want to show you my fucking nuts.
And I'm like,
I guess I appreciate it,
but we should.
Someone sent me some fucking tits
already.
Geez.
Well I think they're coming today.
Today people are going to send you them
that aren't even going to be there.
You're going to get some fake accounts
bringing a shitty hug and it gives a
flat fish catfish,
catfish,
catfish.
If anyone's up,
forget.
Oh,
I,
yeah.
If anyone's up for getting cabinet,
it's always walker champion.
I'll show up with my fucking pants down.
Ready for it.
I'll buy anything.
You know what's funny about you and this
whole thing is that no one had to give
you the green light to do this.
What I love about it is that you decided
to take a chance,
spend your own money,
hire legit musicians,
put it together yourself and you're
like,
fuck it.
I'm going to have it.
Either I'm going to go down in flames or
this is going to take off.
And Dude,
I hear about you all the time now.
Like I don't know if you know what's
happening,
but there's like this wave of people who
are finding out about you across the
country.
The answer is right.
I didn't know.
I mean I put out the album and then I
got a call like I said about,
you know that it's on the billboard.
I thought it was a fucking joke.
And then I,
they said that we should,
I got to go on tour and I said I ain't
going,
I'm no spring chicken man.
I ain't sitting in a fucking van and
playing empty clubs.
And I said call me back when we got
offers and they started getting off
like,
can I make my
officially it was Jamie pull up that uh,
even though I'm announcing it right now,
like,
and I got talked into,
you know like there's people buying,
I guess they want to buy tickets.
I don't,
nobody would have ever let you do this
10 years ago you could've noticed.
That's so funny.
Cause you know obviously a thing,
you know,
here we go.
Bam.
Oh Shit.
It was a total tour son.
I'm not even kidding.
This is some of these is the first time
I seen it.
Okay,
so go to wheeler walker jr com forward
slash tour and all of these are audio.
You can win some serious places,
man.
You're doing some pretty big deals.
Tell me they don't like,
some of these are like,
like house of Blues.
Yeah.
These are several thousand blues.
I mean they don't play,
they play everything but the blues.
But I mean those are big rooms.
How the fuck am I going to sell out out?
I Dunno dude.
I guess is what I'm here for.
I guess that's what you're here for him.
But yeah,
you're playing.
You do in the independent in San
Francisco.
Is that a good place?
It's a very nice place.
Mother fucker got some good spots.
Yeah.
I mean more in Philadelphia.
That's a great theater.
I don't know why.
Yeah,
look at you.
That's hilarious.
I want to go the album come out
Bam.
About eight weeks.
So I listen.
Yeah,
I dunno what the fuck's going on,
but here's awesome.
I guess.
So I went in there,
this guy,
Dave Cobb,
who just won the grammy at the Preuss,
won the grammy for country producer of
the year.
And he did circles first two records and
I knew sturgeon a little bit back in
Kentucky.
And um,
he introduced me,
he's like,
just give me,
I was like,
I want to own this shit.
You know,
I don't want anyone to own it because
they're going to fuck fuck with it.
So I just gave him the,
like literally emptied out my bank
account,
gave Dave the money,
all these kind of the best musicians.
A lot of it was actually a lot of
shooters.
The guys from shooters first band who
would all move who now are in Nashville.
So it's like these killer player too,
I think are the best players in
Nashville.
But they're not like Nashville's go to,
you know,
not like the guys at these pop dog shit
guys go to.
And it's the guys who played on Sturgis
first record and we,
and these guy,
Leroy Powell,
Chris Powell,
Brian now
Brian Allen and give him a shot.
I mean the great musician,
great fucking musicians live versions
that they did.
They did.
You can have the crown live some radio
station thing with just a very small
group of them and you get to see like
how good the,
the,
the actual families struggles guy,
different pain.
Now that again,
I mean fuck stretches.
Paint now as fucking uh,
is killer.
I mean music is so hard to pin down.
It's funny too cause you know we had a
bit of a,
we had a fallen out recently and you
couldn't find a bigger stars will fan
than me.
I just listened to his record on the way
over here and it's a fucking
masterpiece.
But he also won't fucking talk to me
right now.
What happened?
Well here's the thing,
I don't even mind talking about it,
right?
I in an interview I said that he was in,
but this is honestly what I believe.
I think he is.
And you're going to laugh when I say it,
but I swear this is what I fucking
believe.
I think he's a paid ca.
Assess.
I'll just let that sink in for a second.
I think he's taking motherfuckers out
and I confronted him about it.
What did you uh,
get this information?
Well,
let me tell you the video.
None of them.
See I'm not,
like I said,
I knew him back and get,
and Tuckey
and he goes,
is this fucker goes to the navy.
Right?
Right.
Imagine,
imagine being,
imagine he's,
he's worked for the governor.
Imagine being in the navy and you look
next to you.
And some guy just picked up a guitar and
started singing and it sturgill Simpson.
Imagine that,
right?
There's no fucking way,
like the greatest singer,
guitarist,
one of the best ones in the world right
now.
Would you agree with that?
Oh,
for sure.
He's just sit next to you on a fucking
boat and he decides,
you know what,
I want to leave the navy when he was
young.
But I'm saying,
you can't just quit the navy,
uh,
what you do,
you term.
You know,
he didn't do his term.
He fucked it left.
Brilliant.
So He owes the gum.
How long did he go?
I don't know the fuck.
Listen,
all my facts aren't together.
I kind of find me alive.
But he leaves.
Can you do that?
I thought that's like you go awol.
He didn't go awol.
He's fucked.
So why is it,
I'm saying,
why is he fucking out?
Oh,
well you should talk to her house Jones
about that.
Well,
no,
but I'm telling.
I know I'm not,
I don't need to talk to him.
I got the answers.
Okay.
He leaves.
Right?
Right.
Now
he all of a sudden out of nowhere,
he just puts out the fucking wreck.
So if you're in the government,
you want to take some fuckers out,
right?
But their dick in the dirt.
Look,
I'm saying,
take those motherfuckers down.
What's the best way to do it?
And this done,
but may have been done before,
but some,
some other Hollywood stars,
your guest country music artists alive
and you show people for you.
Well,
no.
Yeah,
as a front.
But who travels the most Christian music
artists?
Yeah.
And you gotta have them legit cause he's
got to go fucking play right?
Checkout surgicals tour.
Now,
here's what I'm going to say right now.
I know you're laughing at I,
you both laughed at him,
but this motherfucker,
his toured Europe.
Fucking 10.
He's polite.
He's toured England 10 times.
You ever heard?
Who's your favorite country music
artists from England?
They don't listen to fucking country
music.
They don't listen to it now.
You don't play and listen to it.
He's going over there fucking killing
people and,
but this fucker gone to how many times
you eat a lot.
Do you ever met a Japanese guy and you
go,
who's your favorite country?
Ours.
They don't go,
uh,
you know,
they don't go,
oh fuck a hot dog do.
I can tell you you'll call them.
They don't listen to that shit.
He's over there taking motherfuckers
out.
You go down his tour list and you could
check the,
check it with the papers of enemies of
the state who have been taken out.
That shit fucking lines up,
does it?
I think I wasn't the specifics.
I can't.
Anyway,
I got a little stone and I thought this
was what happened and I should have
asked him about it,
which is true,
but so he just started accusing him of
being a CIA has done to his face.
I did it on a couple of radio shows and
then,
and this is probably going to break it
open a little bit,
but anyway,
now he's,
he won't.
Why will he confront me about it?
Because it's true.
Right?
And why is this new album all about him?
You heard the record.
It just him talking to his son because
he's seeing shit at night.
He,
he's seen the shit,
you know,
why do you write up an album about this?
Serious about doing as like a serious
talk to your child because you've seen
shit go down.
You've seen motherfuckers [inaudible]
he's tells loves his kid.
No one does it.
No,
that's not a reason to make a record.
He says he's telling his kids warning
him don't do what I did.
You know,
and he's a hired government assassin and
I'm almost positive about this and we're
in the it,
but I'm also getting the truth out
there.
Don't you worry,
he's going to take you out for exposing
them.
That's what I'm talking about it.
Because now they know if he takes me
out,
we'll know then my story will be true.
That's what their gut thought in Russia.
Remember that dude in Russia?
They was talking shit about,
uh,
about Putin.
He was a political rival,
the Putin.
And he thought because he was so public,
they'd never take them out.
They shot him with his girlfriend while
he's with his girlfriend.
They shot him in front of a government
building.
Let doesn't help my fucking hang tight
with the store.
They'll just get you,
dude.
You go to Russia,
don't tour Russia.
I don't know.
Well,
I mean again,
I,
I'm,
my facts aren't like a 100% together,
but from what I've seen,
why wouldn't he talk to me about it?
Then you say,
well,
you know,
people get testy when you call him
killers.
They get,
um,
you know,
they feel bad.
I don't know,
man.
Yeah,
you guys.
I mean,
whatever.
I think I'm onto something,
but whatever.
Anyway,
that's the thing about country music.
You live with some friends,
but that 10 taking apart what I that I
think he's a hired government killer.
Take that away.
Take that away for the moment.
But what you're saying about those guys
like surgery,
it's,
it's bringing real country.
It's actual country music.
He didn't play on the radio.
Jason Isbell to dark guy.
Man.
I've been listening to a lot of his shit
lately.
He's amazing.
He's fucking great.
That's the guy who did.
The Guy Dave who did his records did
mine too.
There's a lot of great stuff coming out
right now and what,
see,
this is the thing though.
It seems that
music are a lot
like television producers in that what
they want to do is sell the most shit
and like some of these people,
they're not necessarily there.
It's not that they're not artists.
They're definitely artists.
They're creating music,
but the creating music that they
specifically want to sell a lot,
they want it to hit with people.
It's almost like they want to figure out
how to press those buttons,
right.
You know,
they want to put it in a nice juicy
formula when they get press those
buttons,
right?
And you'll sell a lot of units,
but a guy like sturgeon or a guy like
shooter jennings,
like these guys are not doing that.
What they're doing is expressing
themselves and then you get to find out
who they actually are.
And it's so much more interesting than
the same canned bullshit.
And the same can bullshits fine
sometimes.
I mean sometimes I like listening to
some stupid pop music song just for the
fuck of it.
Who Cares?
It's not the worst thing in the world.
I think that's fine too.
But my,
my actual might even bigger,
not even bigger issue,
but speaking like I like fucking pop
music just like you,
but the country pop his fucking 20 is 30
years is there,
I don't mind.
Like sturgill is a good example of
someone who's taken country and moving
it forward.
These guys aren't,
they're adding beats from like the
eighties and they're,
they're going backwards.
You know,
they're trying,
I know people who go into studios of
major country artists with one of those
fucking clickers clicker things and
making sure it's the right is not made
up.
Making sure it's the right beats per
minute.
So slow it down,
speed up to make sure we get on the
radio.
So my goal with my record,
it's in that fucking crazy.
That's weird that like,
that's you imagine someone coming in
here with one of those clickers.
It speed up or slow down your Po,
like you fucking kick him out of the
room.
Well we've talked about this a hundred
times.
Like if we actually had a network or a
producer or an executive behind the
showed it never worked.
No one had never let us do any of this
stuff.
How would it had arguments with people
every day about some of the things we
say,
hey tell totally.
And that's why the podcast so great and
so big and a lot of these pots,
you know,
it's,
it's a natural reaction when like,
you know,
radio turns to shit.
Yeah.
Podcast had to happen because people
were sick of bullshit radio in the same
thing with country.
I went,
basically my goal was I said,
I gave him cash.
I said,
no one's touching this,
and I said,
I'm going to make the best country
record of the year and I'm going to make
it completely unplayable.
I don't want it to be able to be played
anywhere.
So when you're making out Mike,
that you're literally only listening,
you're not thinking outside the room.
You recorded it because the assumption
was nobody was going to fucking hear it.
So when you make an album that you
assumed,
nobody's going to hear it.
It's an interesting shit kind of
happened.
Yeah,
got it.
Got fucking dirty.
You don't get me wrong.
I mean it went fucking x rated,
but it's fun,
man.
It's fun.
And what you said was true to like 20
years ago,
1510 years ago,
this would have to be sold in the back
of a Nudie Mag.
It's on Itunes,
it's on Amazon.
It's not,
like I said,
it's not Walmart.
You had to give it to people and they
would have had to start talking about
it.
And then there was a few a warrant
there,
few like dirty albums or guys would sink
dirty
his back.
And David Allan Coe,
the most famous,
I actually opened up to shows for David
Allen Coe.
And he's dirty.
No,
no,
he's a legit country artist and it's
actually a real story.
It's interesting.
He,
um,
Shel Silverstein was a,
the writer,
a country,
you know the kids children's book
writer,
but he also wrote country music.
He wrote boy named sue for Johnny Cash.
Somebody told me that.
That's true.
He ain't,
he's recorded here and there.
So David Allan Coe was playing these
really dirty,
these really dirty songs for Shel
Silverstein.
And he goes,
you got to record this shit.
And I got a great record label.
I can't,
you know,
this is the seventies I can't record.
I mean,
we're talking
should I would,
I mean like,
I consider myself an equal opportunity
offender and I'm a David Allan Coe fan.
I mean,
no disrespect,
but it's,
you know,
70 he's used as for f and I don't think
he's a racist because it comes up a lot.
But he used the n word,
you know,
it gives crazy shit and those decks,
but it was sold and he recorded it
obviously off the radar and it was sold
in the back of backer mags,
you know,
and those albums they got to me and
Kentucky,
you know,
like they get around but it was just,
it was a different machine behind him.
Well do you remember the Jerky Boys?
Yeah.
Do you remember they had a,
there was a cassette that you would get
from people.
That's how we all got the Jerky boys.
I remember getting that in Kentucky.
Just like you got to hear this part.
Cause we all used to do prank calls.
Like you got to hear this shit.
I think those guys did that shit all on
their own and put the thing,
didn't they do a movie?
You probably won't go mainstream,
but it went south there.
But again,
but what you're saying is totally right.
Like,
and now you've got word of mouth.
That's how you ended up on the billboard
charts is when you got word of mouth
plus the Internet,
which is instead of town 10 French,
you're actually telling a thousand
friends and we're outselling,
you know,
my album came out the same week as a new
Wynnona judd record and sold more copies
and I'm from Kentucky and I got nothing
against,
I've got nothing against the judge,
by the way.
Did I tell you I got in a twitter fight
with Wendona.
Whoa.
For Real?
Yeah.
Which one's the actress at her sister
Ashley.
Well known.
Uh,
looks like,
uh,
to Ashley's put together.
I don't rude.
Um,
yeah,
that's not nice of me to say.
I don't like these La Women.
I should say that.
You like them thick.
Yeah.
Like it could have been like a moral
third.
Yeah.
I don't like these girls to too because
it's like the old days,
you know,
if he said girl is skinny healthy.
Yeah.
It was a sign of that in the like those
fat kings in the old days,
you know,
or like they let them let you know that
they had fucking money.
You and I see a girl is skinny.
I think they're just using me for food.
What if women think that way?
They see a guy was real thin.
Like to they,
they want a guy with a gut secretly.
They don't want to talk about it with
corn.
What I've seen in La,
yeah,
what he wants.
I mean these geese,
girls look hungry.
There's a lot of hungry girls and all
that.
They are hungry.
Well they been told that they have to be
a fucking coat rack in order to be
famous.
Guys don't like,
well not only that man,
watch television.
Other companies like watch a television
show in Columbia.
All the girls have these big thick ass
legs,
big asses and big tits.
They don't look anything like American
women and that's what fucking we whack
off
to X.
Like I've never googled skinny chicks on
my fucking oh but healthy.
I hate to bring it back to me,
but please do.
It goes,
but it goes to what we're talking about.
You're doing everything the opposite
way.
So I go,
so a lot of these albums nowadays,
like you know,
they'll do those,
they'll stream,
you know,
do a free stream the week before it
comes out on NPR or rolling stone or
wherever it was.
And you know,
no one play my shit of course.
So I go,
let's um,
let's premiere the um,
the record on um,
on red tube.
No,
what,
which one was it like a porn site?
Yeah,
Porno Porn.
Pornhub was the one I did go porn hub.
I go,
let's,
let's stream down for free for the first
week on porn hub.
All right.
I think maybe,
listen,
don't get me wrong.
Most people who went to porn hub that
week,
we're looking to hear a country music
record.
Right?
But still,
you get 1% of that.
They,
they're whack off.
And we knew I'm lacking off.
Listen to a good fucking record.
They had ads for my record.
No one's read.
I was like,
they basically said to me like,
let's just try it out and see what
happens.
And they were so totally fucking cool
about it.
It's like when you're looking for cause
this like,
they're like talking about these like
you know nprs app.
Oh it's at 10,000 people like,
how'd you like to reach every fucking
man on earth?
Who Wax off?
I go,
yeah,
that sounds interesting to me.
That sounds like an audience I'd like to
get him with.
Do you ever look at ads when you whack
off though?
I had not.
I don't even know what.
Here's my theme and notice them.
I go full screen immediately.
Now my theory though is when you might
face is up there and you're whack.
If you just right when you see my face,
you ain't forgetting that face for the
rest of your fucking life.
Good point.
You have a very distinct look and then
the,
if you like,
went to like a video that you really
enjoyed and then your face was off to
the side of it.
It could get confusing.
We yell,
it's a click.
It clicked right to the fucking record.
Yeah.
That's like some Manchurian candidate
type shit.
Yeah,
that's how I'm thinking.
I'm thinking sturge we'll lock here
dude.
I see what you're saying.
Like you just get in their head like,
yeah cause every,
I wonder like what are the real raw
numbers?
Like how many people jerk off to those
porn sites?
Well they,
I mean they told me they was like the,
it has to be insane.
It was hundreds of,
you know,
it was literally hundreds of millions.
Well they're like,
you know it was,
isn't that fucking crazy?
They're like,
what's crazy is it's in the dark.
If there was any other fucking website
that had hundreds of millions of hits,
we'd be talking about it all the time.
Exactly.
Well that's the thing.
They gave me their numbers and they were
just like,
they weren't even that,
cause they know the numbers.
So to them it's not a big deal.
They're like,
I go help.
Like compare yourself to other sites.
Like what's it like compared to
craigslist was only thing.
I said they go,
oh we're bigger than craigslist.
What about CNN were bigger?
It's CNN.
I go,
wow,
this guy's combined.
Why the fuck am I is am I the only one
thinking to put to fucking put ads on
pornhub?
And they go,
because the corporations won't.
This is back to me paying for it,
knowing that myself,
I go,
I can do whatever they want.
We've asked a movie studios,
you've asked the record companies,
they won't fucking put ads on our
fucking sites.
And I go,
I'll fucking do it.
That's because,
and I go and they who do you have to
talk to to do it?
And I go,
you're talking to the fucking guy.
You know?
That's the whole,
don't have people.
That's the whole love of the whole great
thing about doing this legacy.
But you must have people swooping in on
you now because of what we're talking
about earlier that Nashville right now,
I don't want to say it like I'm a
fucking investigator.
I've been studying Nashville.
He was like,
she,
you know the big picture,
that's money.
It's just like television shows.
If you want to watch those terrible two
and a half men style television shows.
Why do you think they're making those
things?
Because people are buying them.
They're gobbling them up.
There's a certain frequency that you can
hit when you make like really dull,
bland stuff.
And people like that.
There's a lot of people that like that.
And so they know how to do it and they
bang it out.
And I think that's what's happening with
producers,
but it's not what the public wants.
And that's why you're getting these
shows like mad men or you know,
walking dead or you know,
the,
the game of thrones,
you're getting these interesting shows
that are so much different than all
these formulaic bullshit shows that had
been on television forever.
And because people were changing.
They have to,
they have to adapt to the fact that
people have too many options now.
They don't have to just eat your spoon
fed bullshit.
Totally.
I mean,
that's,
that's like,
uh,
you know,
listen,
and the girl who dumped me,
and I'm telling you she's not a bitch,
but when she left my,
and in my head,
I'm thinking,
fuck as any guy would fuck you,
bitch.
I go,
why do I have to cover up that emotion
that I felt after the song for some
fucking record label?
So I just sang,
fuck you.
But of course everyone that's the
studious guys are playing drums.
Like what the Fuck's wrong with this?
Is that video have on Youtube?
It's something insane.
Oh,
it's not that.
I mean,
we're still at the very beginnings.
what's so crazy is,
you know the amount of records I sold,
these rooms I'm playing,
we still only reached a friend because
you know,
there's just for eight weeks,
man.
Yeah,
it's prettier.
But there's this band Florida,
Georgia line who by the way,
just blocked me on twitter because I was
talking so much shit about it.
Florida,
Georgia,
Georgia line,
George.
And they're one of the,
one of the bigger acts and country.
And listen,
I'm sure they're not.
I heard later,
they were nice guys after I ripped on
him for fucking nonstop for fucking,
you have 72 hours.
But I don't give two fucks about making
fun of this bullshit pop country that I
call,
you know,
that I talked about before.
So I'll fucking rip on there.
That pop country,
they have to,
I had a wallet chain until recently.
Okay.
Listen to,
I mean,
don't you tell me right now those dudes
ain't about to attack each other off.
They're trying to get some pussy.
They look good.
I look to shave their arms.
Hold on.
Go back to that Jamie.
These are you guys trying to get pussy
the guy in the over his right shoulder?
No,
that guy's not good pussy.
But in his defense he might've already
gotten some pussy or he might be in the
devil.
He's in post pussy.
Yeah,
he could it be like,
I just nodded so hard today.
I don't care about fuck,
I just want to eat some cheetos and take
a nap.
That's very possible.
Yeah.
I mean that's the guy at the right.
Doesn't know what the fuck's going on.
The Guy,
the far right with the glasses with a
gray shirt.
He's just like hoping one day talking to
Max.
He just wants to the checks to cash.
Yeah.
He's hoping one day it's all gonna make
sense.
But right now he's baffled.
He's like,
is on the right.
Here's
the thing,
if it makes people happy and people like
this fucking crap,
hey,
he's,
you know,
I liked their medallions but the fake
soldiers,
I got nothing against it,
but I'm also the only fucking dude in
Nashville talking shit about,
about him and Sam Hunt,
this guy who fucking wraps and you know,
why does that guy have a dog tag on and
go back to that please.
Jamie,
he's got a diamond and crusted dog tag.
That should be,
that's like some stolen valor shit.
Maybe he works for us.
Yeah,
I mean that is the exact opposite of
what a fucking dog tag is.
A dog tag is aluminum and it represents
a memory of someone who died in the war.
This is a dog tag shaped diamond
encrusted thing.
This is,
this is hilarious is the real dog tags
aren't diamond and crest.
Is that what you're trying to,
so I'm trying to say this is the,
I mean this is literally like the devil
is selling us a band.
It really,
but this is the thing.
This is what they're selling.
So you wonder why I'm pissing off music
row.
Well,
here's a reason because that fucking
bands has blocked wheeler walker jr on
twitter.
It's probably someone handling their
shit,
whatever it is.
And again,
I've heard they're nice enough guys,
but there there's people writing the
music for him there.
The people producing it for him.
There's a,
sure,
let me just use him as settings.
Let me just say in broader terms,
listen,
I don't another thing he knows other
thing reason I think people dig me cause
I don't give a fuck if I'm saying it's
too,
I just say the shit.
But the pop country dog shit that's on
country radio with Florida,
Georgia line,
same hunt and all this other shit.
I mean listen,
listen to some of it.
I don't know what it sounds like.
It sounds like what's Steve Earl said?
It sounds like the guys they're
dreaming.
I think you're hating.
Fuck yeah mate.
I'm trying to sell record.
Go back to him.
Jamie who get the one with the gold
bullion.
He's got a gold bullion around his neck,
some shit.
Columbus took over in the Santa Maria.
Go back to them.
Another one,
the original picture that you had.
And while these guys are beautiful,
there he goes,
look at the gold bullion handsome.
They look like they'd be wonderful to
hang out with.
And you think those two guys know what's
locked to have loved and lost.
And those guys hadn't been down that
dirt road,
sir.
They've got their fingers dirty and
everything.
They have hand sanitizer in their back
pocket right now.
No,
ain't no,
ain't no girl dumping those dudes with
those blue gold crusted madame bomb.
Girls are crazy.
They don't even appreciate what's in
front of them.
You want to hear that?
No,
you want to hear some fucking,
uh,
you know,
some heartbreak you listened to me.
Not these two fucking good looking dude.
Well,
for heartbreak music,
I would say the dude with the red and
black striped shirt is not going to give
you what you're looking for.
Yeah,
probably not.
I wonder if he,
I don't think he's,
I think it's just the two dudes he
wishes he was in the cure,
but they're not taking anybody new.
You know what's funny?
I'll bet the two guys in the front.
I'll bet Damian Ammann he met the band.
I would if they become my favorite band
though.
Like we're talking all this mad shit,
but I haven't listened to the music.
What if we play their music right now?
And I'm like,
Oh my God,
I love them and I'm fucking,
I'll see you later.
You just leave Ali.
No play.
Can we hear some?
Well,
I've got to tell you.
Oh,
you get in trouble?
Yeah.
We'll probably get pulled from youtube,
right?
How do do this?
Uh,
you know what?
How about this?
They say a little bit,
just not play a little tube.
Can't hear it.
Okay.
Youtube.
Anybody listening to on Youtube?
What's the song?
Just tell us what the song is,
but the people on the podcast can hear
it,
right?
Is that how it goes?
The first one that popped up is called
confession.
Jamie might have to do some editing.
We're going to get polled.
Can't be use ash.
We're going to call called confession.
It's weird.
Here we go.
Florida,
Georgia Line Confession,
7 million million golf.
7 million views.
Now compare that to Sturgis.
Just keep,
I keep playing.
This guy's keeping it real.
Now hear that.
Hear that?
That,
that the drum or whatever that is.
Yeah.
Oh,
that beat the rap.
Yeah,
he's doing Rambo.
He's rapping
now.
You tell me.
This is country music.
Honestly,
it's weird.
It's pop music like it's like a poppy
poppy.
Yeah.
They're doing a lot of hip hop movements
with their hands.
It's all like they're stealing from
black people.
It's cultural appropriation.
Tony should end it.
We should end.
Listen,
white people have never stopped stealing
from black people.
They're not going to stop.
They're moving into country music.
Was He right though?
It's,
it's,
yeah.
It's wrapped for people who are scared
of black people.
That's 100% rav.
For people that are scared of black,
catchy tune,
it probably sold.
Well,
obviously we'll fucking more than me,
but I'm not,
like I said,
I'm the only one who's,
and what you were saying,
people coming at me,
which has been happening some,
but for the most part,
they don't want to piss off the real
money maker so they don't want to be
associated with that.
It seems like there's a lot of country
music that's sort of reinforcing of
mindset and so one of the only music
genres that reinforces a mindset and
that mindset is,
I'm a simple person.
I got a nice truck,
I got a good dog,
I got a woman,
but someone broke my heart.
Or maybe I love you,
maybe I'd die for you.
There's like all these like really no
bull and really,
uh,
really like iconic like country music
themes and,
and a iconic country music ideas that
get pushed in these and they just get
repeated over and over and over again.
It's reinforcing the benefits of living
in a rural environment.
It's reinforcing being near nature and
rivers and shit like that.
But it's also reinforcing being dumb.
It's reinforcing like God got to have
God involved.
There's a lot of God involved and
there's some of that shit that I
listened to.
Why go?
This can't be real.
I don't think surgical simpson is a CIA
assassin,
but I've listened to some country music
songs where I go,
okay,
this is a fucking cyber plot.
This is the government is trying to
figure out how to get into people's
minds and make them dumber.
Well,
the other thing too is as a guy from
[inaudible] and I'm with you 100% right,
but seems like it totally
it,
it feels like it was made to brainwash.
It's a psych psych,
psy ops.
Is that what they call those things?
The government's just created super
popular music that enforces the idea of
being stupid.
Totally.
But also as the guy from Kentucky,
I grew up in Kentucky,
must my family from Tennessee and it
makes me look like a fucking dumb ass
that like this is what people,
this is not what the south is.
I got a lot of really all my friends are
from itself.
It's great man.
Yeah,
it's all the best for me.
You know it's the fucking great
greatest,
but you see this and that's what
reinforced,
not only say cultural appropriation,
it's reinforcing stereotypes.
So I'm going in there and making some
real,
what?
I actually would have less of a problem
if they just didn't,
if they just called that pop music,
it's pop music.
Why Co?
Because they're given an act.
It's pop music with an accent and that
accent is what makes it country.
But it's also,
they don't,
there's very little bragging.
It's not like hip hop.
Hip Hop is like a lot about bragging,
you know,
there's a lot of like,
yeah,
there's a lot of what I'm going to do to
use a lot of what I own.
What am I gonna do to your girl?
You have a totally,
this is,
this is like your rice together with you
forever.
Yeah.
I never going to leave you.
I appreciate you.
And they're backstage,
you know,
fucking dual blow bang guys.
Jank you jacking each other off the 69
spinning in a circle.
That's the tweet that got me blocked to
think.
Yeah,
that'll do it.
They're probably not.
They're probably nice.
Guys.
I heard they were nice guys,
but it has nothing.
And if they are listening,
which they're not,
but it's a great job.
I'm sure they're happy,
they get 7 million.
But it's not that,
it's not them personally,
it's just that machine that Nashville is
putting out that I'm so against.
And I decided that it pisses me off that
it's that country music,
which I love so much and I love,
but that's not the stuff we've been
talking.
You know,
my heroes,
waylon and willie and Johnny Cash,
Johnny Cash and Merle just passed away
and like the Louvin brothers just passed
away.
Um,
Louvin brothers or banner do what this
country do.
I use to love and they're singing about,
they had to sell him.
Satan is real and almost looks like a
joke where they're sick,
but it's like,
but they're serious.
They're serious.
Satan is real,
but they're real.
But they're,
but they're talking about,
you know,
the struggle of the devil versus like,
that's interesting to me.
Like,
okay,
yeah,
they know I'm not,
you know,
I don't,
it's hard to sing sing when I sing and
talk about that.
But if they're talking about the
struggle between the two sides and then
maybe I can listen,
but if you're just talking about this,
this is pop music.
It's ain't country.
So that's why I decided not to censor
myself on the record.
It's like if I'm going to duke real
country and ain't going to get played on
country radio,
no matter what I do,
it doesn't matter anymore though.
It does it.
I mean did you please check this,
cause I'm not sure if it's true.
Some of the comedy store was saying that
CBS is unloading all of its radio
properties.
They are a,
I've heard they're currently exploring
options on what to do with their stuff.
I don't know that it's officially how
well how can we,
who would be listening to,
nobody listens to the radio.
It sounds like shit.
It's not nearly as good as a CD or an
MP.
Three in your car.
Right.
How's that hd radios that,
okay.
I've never heard of it.
It like if you,
this is radio show,
what would I be on here for two and a
half minutes and it would be censored.
You can't talk about the record and then
we would have to say traffic brought to
you by pet code.
You have a cute little dog or a kitten
cut up,
had co get 'em ground up murder that I'm
lost.
We'll be right back.
Uh Yeah,
we'd have to,
I've done a couple of those because it's
country radio literally won't have me
on.
So I did a couple of rock of
terrestrial,
whatever they call it,
rock stations because they were kind of
into it.
So he's got a new album called redneck
stuff,
you know,
it's like they can't even say it.
So then people,
it doesn't even help me cause they go on
Itunes,
they can't find the name of the record.
What do you remember that Cee Lo Green
Song?
Fuck you,
that they turned into forget you and
they kept kept going.
You knew you would hear it somewhere and
you would go,
you fucking,
why did you make a second version of
this?
What did you do?
Well,
that's my thing is I've been asked the
other thing,
which you know,
you kind of getting to,
I have been asked many times to make
censored versions of these songs.
And I wrote and I wrote back to me
owning it.
No,
it ain't happening.
I can't believe that.
Talk Cee Lo and know it.
Well that's,
but when you're on a major label and
you're,
and they're paying for all your shit,
you know?
Yeah.
You're,
you're on.
She got to do when you're on tour.
And that's the other thing when I was
talking about,
I aint touring until I got an audience,
but like someone like him and he's on
tour,
the giant band and the record companies
front and the bill,
but he's got to end up paying it back.
It's okay.
Yeah.
You're going to put out the censored
version.
Yeah.
But if you're not,
uh,
you know,
if no co giant corporations behind me
like the,
this is all,
you know,
this is my label.
I could take it off the market today if
I want to do,
I'm not going to,
cause this is,
I'm on a big podcast here and I want to
sell some stuff wreck,
but I could,
you know,
well,
I think what,
what's happened with this is a lot,
there's a lot going on on the Internet
with people just making stuff and
selling stuff.
Just whatever it is.
Whether it's like there's,
there's people that are doing like Louis
Ck is doing that.
Horace and pete show.
What'd he say on stern that he fucking
did you hear about that?
Spent all his money making his horse and
pete show himself when he sell and run
his website just because he wanted to do
it,
but also he wanted to do it himself.
He said,
why don't have nobody involved just so
they get it all himself.
That's really,
it.
Wasn't that the same thing with your
pocket?
Isn't that the lesson really is if,
why not only do things if you're willing
to put up your own fucking money,
two and a half men or what you were
talking about,
that kind of shit.
Oh fuck yeah.
Make it three.
If I'm,
if the whole thing's a bust,
I s I lose zero.
Well,
if this is a bust,
I lose a lot of money.
You lose money if your podcast goes up,
you know,
it's also,
they make it seem so easy.
Like if you're going to do a record with
some major label,
they're going to take care of
everything.
We let her,
don't you worry about a thing guys at a
big saw,
cigars going to get in the elevator with
you and bring you up to the top floor.
You're going to glad hand a bunch of
people were really behind this record.
Wheeler,
we love you.
Oh my God,
I'm a fan.
I listen to your stuff in the car.
I was crying laughing.
Ha Ha.
One are performing.
We'd like to see it when you're coming
to town,
just total bullshit.
You,
you leave and then another guy goes in,
they do the same fucking thing.
They don't really give a fuck about you
hope that you'll make some money and
they'll kind of protect me.
Maybe they like you,
but most likely they liking me.
It's not
to,
ain't got nothing to do with it.
Because when they heard the record and I
went to the top of the top of those big
brokers,
cutting companies and I sat there and
they loving it,
it's blah blah blah.
But all,
you know,
we got to cut this song and we got it.
Take this line out and I the second they
said that I just sit in the room fucking
deal.
You know,
you know I took the meetings,
I figured it's worth taking.
You know,
I'll listen to them.
But that's,
and I will tell you this and this is a
credit to the producer Dave,
when he told me,
told me how much it costs and listen,
it was pretty much all the money I had,
but it was not a cre.
The amount of money that it cost to make
a record in 2016 is not that much
fucking money.
When you look,
when you look at it,
right to sell years fucking the labels
will make it cost a million by charging
you all that fucking bullshit.
And you know,
ordering pizzas everyday that you don't
want and you know,
hiring all these big gun players and
shit,
people are making albums on their
fucking compete.
It doesn't,
it don't cost shit.
You know,
I went a little higher but it,
even that my jaw dropped when he told me
the prize.
It was,
and I don't want to say,
you know,
say the number,
but it was how come?
Because I don't want to put him in,
you know,
like I don't want people to come to him
like,
oh,
you charged him so and so and all that.
And also since then he's also his last
director.
I mean he's sold millions of records
since then,
so as I'm sure it was price is going up.
But,
but he's also,
I'm not sure if some,
if he loved it,
an artist,
he'd just,
he'd record them for fucking free.
But if he's some of the big label,
you know,
he'll take whatever you know,
well,
aren't music producers and a lot of
ways,
a lot like musicians and that they love,
they enjoy making good stuff.
And I know a lot of musicians,
they'll do each other's albums.
They essentially do it for free.
They go and they'll do a cameo on each
other.
Shit.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean I can't say enough.
I almost feel guilty mentioning him
cause he's,
you know my,
you know how he does some good shit that
so no,
I don't want to,
you know,
talk about him producing it is dirty
shit.
But he did such a fucking amazing job
when he's such a music fan that he knows
and he's kind of from the south.
He said this,
I've noticed that people like that.
People I sturge Joel shooter,
we all had the same kind of music was
same kind of upbringing,
which was grew up in the south country
music everywhere and you're like fuck
this,
I'm not listening to friends in low
places or whatever.
You start listening to Zap when you
start listening to rock and you start
going to all this other,
it's all the exact same thing and then
you come back to
weigh on didn't become oil until that he
was late thirties at least like that.
That's not music for kids.
You know,
there's a reason why I didn't get waylon
when I was 11 and you get older and you
listen to it and you're like,
now I fucking get you.
Come back around to it.
And that's what happened to a lot of me
and my friends.
Like this is as real and as fucking
dark.
And as you know,
as a bare bones is any fucking Zeppelin
I ever heard.
And I love Zeppelin too.
You know,
it's the same shit,
but that kind of shit is not available
anymore.
It's legit.
It's a legit,
if it's a rock song,
the black keys are legit.
You know,
there's bands that are just legit.
You listen to their shit and just go
wow.
And then there's stuff that you listened
to that even if you enjoy it,
you know it's heavily produced and
someone created it in a pot factory and
it just doesn't,
it doesn't hit you the same way.
And the crazy thing is too is like you
listen to someone like you really got to
see,
and I hate to use it,
but like I know sturge we'll just
example we're using,
you got to see him alive because
nowadays they can make anybody sound
the,
he doesn't use second auto tune,
but when you see him alive you go,
Holy Shit.
He was just singing on the record.
Yeah.
I could sing.
You know,
I could go sang some auto tune.
Yeah.
With the audit cut up.
You got the look,
you got everything.
You knew some like Peter Frampton ship
and when we used to do,
do you feel like I do,
he was like the first guy to use auto
tune.
Wasn't that auto tune?
I think that was a different thing.
A voco you know that thing with the
guitar?
Like no,
I don't think that was up to you,
but I mean,
no,
I've had,
what was it called?
The talk box.
Talk Box.
All right,
James.
I had a friend who worked who,
who uh,
auto tune a major country pop star.
Whoa.
And he said my voice was fucking better.
Congratulations.
And I said who looked better and I
didn't.
I won't tell you that you don't get a
response.
Well,
I think there's nothing wrong with
making those two and a half men shows.
There's nothing wrong with what we're
talking about.
But as far as like what interest me,
I'm not interested in those poppy songs.
It's just,
it goes in my head and my head just
starts rejecting it.
Like,
oh,
you're eating plastic.
Get it out of there.
You know,
it's like you could,
you could live for like a few days off
of hostess cupcakes if you wanted to.
You could probably live for a month.
Oh,
but just hostess cupcakes.
I wouldn't recommend it though.
Yeah,
I would.
I would definitely not recommend that.
I mean,
that'd be fucking your,
your brain.
Your brain would probably fucking,
you probably have no,
no protein,
no vitamins.
How long could you live off hostess
cupcakes?
That's gotta be the equivalent of just
going without food.
Right.
There would be a really interesting
experiment.
Yeah,
they should do that.
We could do that red band,
red band,
be willing to do that.
That's supersize me guy.
He did.
Oh,
he just said fast food.
He did fast food,
but if someone just eight hosts,
a lot of people just eat fast food.
That didn't really count.
That's normal.
Yeah.
Well,
some people.
Amen.
I don't know.
People have criticized that show.
That movie supersize me like all of his
liver damage,
all that stuff.
They were like,
come on.
Yeah.
Well I remember he like,
he threw up on day one a festival all
the time.
You don't fucking Barf,
but he wasn't saying it's Vegan or
something.
Before that,
it was like super healthy.
Before that was a Vegan chef or
something.
Yeah,
but also I always get pissed when I see
you moving like that and they're like
any in conclusion,
fast food is not good for you.
I'm like,
oh,
thanks.
Anymore fucking brain busters.
Well,
not only that,
they say don't,
don't need it every day.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to eat it every day.
That fast food is supposed to be a
guilty thing that you eat when you got
no time to do anything else.
Like you want to just pull on the Burger
King.
All right,
fuck it.
Let's do this.
That's what it's supposed to be.
Twice a year you get hung over and you
go to fucking Jack in the box.
Above is fine.
It's no big deal.
They don't,
the people that aren't like thinking of
slinging health food,
you know?
Yeah.
Well they're trying to catch up to that
now though.
You see like Mcdonald's has salads.
What's,
imagine how nasty that is.
Oh my God,
their salad.
What does it tastes like?
Like Fukushima letters?
What if it,
what if it was like the best salad
you've ever had?
It's,
it's possible.
Yeah,
it is totally possible.
Like you just don't want it.
Like that's,
there are new,
a sponsor on your fucking show.
Yeah.
Have you ever had any big corporate
sponsors on here?
No.
I prefer to do it the way we're doing it
to mostly companies that sell things
only online.
Well that's squarespace and stuff like
that.
Oh,
we,
I think the website development company
I've got,
I've gotten emails from,
I think they do my website well,
you can make your own website on them.
It's super easy to do.
But there's like a lot of companies that
they're using the internet now and using
podcasts,
the sponsors,
because they don't have to have a store,
they don't have to have like a retail
place and have to have a bunch of
employees that were an Abercrombie and
Fitch spray.
They can just sell stuff online.
I think someone was telling me at the,
at the place that distributes the record
that
80 more or something,
more percent of my albums sold have been
itunes and Amazon because people can't
find,
there's no way to,
the stores aren't carrying.
Yeah.
And now one can find it.
And when I was a kid and when you were a
kid,
if you,
even if word of mouth got to you about
this record,
you couldn't buy it.
You went in Kentucky.
I went to the record store.
I remember I want,
someone was telling me about the velvet
underground.
I got to go here,
velvet underground.
So I went to this local record store and
uh,
in,
in Lexington and uh,
they look it up in the catalog.
Like,
yeah,
it'll be four weeks and we'll get it to
you.
He be like four weeks to hear what this
band sounds like.
And then he had a high from a catalog.
Yeah,
he'd be,
they had a catalog of all every record
cause no one in there's buying it.
So why would they order it?
Wow.
So you have to order it and then you
just have to buy it and listen to it
because you're not going to hear it
anymore.
That's what we're asked to me is the big
thing has changed music.
Like I used to again,
I was,
you know,
even Lexan,
which is not that small of a town.
You're an island.
Rarely.
So you would get rolling stone.
You read about like the Jesus Lizard.
I don't know if you remember that band
really hardcore.
They were really cool.
And I remember the guy writing about the
Jesus Lizard in Rolling Stone said it.
They're like,
the real,
at least is not a joke.
These fuckers are fucking crazy.
And it's the craziest music.
Whenever they said got me wind listened
to it.
Nowadays you read that you don't need
the article,
you just click on the fucking music.
Right.
But I had to wait weeks to fucking hear
that shit.
You can't press on the fucking article
and it's like the mystery of it's gone.
But that being said,
the positive is that I can actually sell
my,
my record fucking m street.
It's all positives to me.
You can sell your record also that like,
like people could start talking about
you through twitter and facebook and
things along those lines and it just
spreads across the whole country like
that.
Well,
can you imagine even 10 years ago or if
not more like,
like I'm,
I'm banned from Walmart.
Imagine getting that call 10 years ago.
You're gestating devastating.
This wasn't even,
it's like a divorce.
It doesn't even matter.
Of course you're going to be banned from
Walmart does honor.
Yeah.
I think they probably use just like they
just,
they probably band 50 other records.
Yeah.
Band.
So much shit.
But there's this whole,
what you are talking about,
all this shit,
they feed you.
There's,
and listen,
it ain't going to sell a million fucking
copies,
but there's people that,
there's a section of,
you know the audience that wants real
shit and they put a section of the of
your of people are sick.
I'm sick of the fucking radio.
I just want to hear Joe Talk to somebody
in a fucking conference and you just
listen.
I'm sure you still do radio promote
shows and shit like that.
You don't need started to collect Kevin
and bean cause they're friends.
Oh yeah,
no I didn't.
They're a,
they're a charity thing.
They're awesome.
Most of the time I'm not doing that much
right.
Anyway,
that's awesome.
See I talked too much already.
I don't want to talk more,
but that's all.
First of all,
I'm jealous,
but then the second of all,
it's awesome that you got a big enough
platform that you can,
you don't have to do it.
Yeah,
it's super fortunate,
but I mean it's not that I didn't enjoy
doing some radio,
but the problem is for us,
it's in the morning.
Like for me,
it's always at like six o'clock in the
morning or seven o'clock in the morning.
Oh,
you're preaching to the converted.
I'm like,
I'm not going to get up.
I've had to,
you know,
get up at seven to do fucking radio idea
that you can only listen to it at a
specific time is so fucking stupid.
Like you don't have to do that anymore.
We have a way better way of getting
stuck.
So funny you said that.
So I'm so dumb.
It's like who are they fooling?
Like why?
Why do you think like podcasts would
have,
we're going to happen no matter what
happens.
If it was just bad,
I don't know who fucking started,
but it had to happen because people want
to listen to what they want and what to
do and when you fucking get startup your
car again,
you want to listen to where you left
off,
left off and it just syncs up to cart.
Rocket Science.
No.
Yeah,
you get it with one press of a button.
I can go to the my podcast.
I can go to the podcast APP and itunes.
I look at the the podcast,
I said,
oh,
we were walking junior,
boom,
I touch it.
I can do all this at a red light.
And then my car,
the light turns green.
I start driving and I'm listening to you
like that.
It's just so easy and murder.
The old days you'd go,
Oh,
stern a interviewed Chris Rock.
He missed it.
Why?
What are we leaving?
How did I miss it?
Like that's no,
that's not the world we live in anymore.
You know,
so fucking get with the time.
So there's a lot of people still
clinging onto the old,
you know how things you like,
like you said,
people need to watch a show at a certain
time or listen to the radio,
like drive time.
Right.
What the fuck?
Who listens to radio on the fucking
drive and the will,
the first thing that switched it up with
Sirius Xm,
cause when serious,
when it was x Sam,
you know,
and a opie and anthony were on and
Howard stern's on what they figured out
when they were doing this.
Or it's like,
look,
we don't have to have any censorship.
We could say whatever the fuck we want.
But they started getting in trouble too.
Like opie and Anthony got banned off the
air once because they brought in a
homeless guy and he started talking
about banging Condoleezza Rice.
Oh I didn't,
I did open anything.
They were cool.
I didn't want of them,
but it's not opening anthony now opiate
and Jimmy Anthony's got his own thing
now he's got,
yeah,
he got care radio.
But I remember it was funny too because
I think you're right
about that.
Sirius Xm was one a big thing.
Cause I remember when hat on stern who I
used to listen to,
who,
by the way,
I lived in,
let's do later because Kentucky,
my home town didn't have stern going on.
But I started listening to him and I
loved him and the city is going to sell
like radio where can say wherever it
wants and they're like,
well,
he's not going to be as funny.
Half the fun is listen to him trying to
talk around and then you listen and you
go,
that's such a fucking,
it's so much fucking funny.
Or when he's not.
He's just saying it.
That idea that it's,
it's more fun to be censored.
Love when people proof theory's wrong.
You know that's a dump theory though.
That's like,
didn't you hear that all the time?
I heard that all the fucking time.
Never heard that I see here that about
comedy,
but I was always like whatever.
Sam kinison and Richard Pryor,
my all time favorites.
Like how the fuck can you tell me who's
funnier?
And Richard Pryor.
I mean,
it was funny.
The Richard Pryor and how could you tell
me that beating around the Bush would be
better than what prior was doing?
You can't,
you can't say you have to be quiet and
maybe it was more in the south,
but I kept hearing,
you know,
now that he's not got like the FCC to
fight against and he can,
you know,
the fun was him trying to get around the
census and he really listened to it and
you go,
it's so much fucking better now that you
know shit.
Just to be free.
Completely free to express yourself
without any worry about a word that's
going to get you fine for hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
And you got to remember like he got,
he got sued by the FCC,
right?
Like [inaudible] task.
He had to go to court over that shit and
they wound up finding him like ungodly
amounts of money and there was nobody
out there with him when he was doing
that.
Like he's this,
one of the reasons why I'll never
criticize that guy.
He's like,
he's like one of the most important
pioneers when it comes to radio.
Like if it wasn't for that guy and going
out there like that and getting sued
and,
and having,
there was all during the fucking Bush
administration man when they were those
johnny and Jack fucking time.
Yeah,
those John Ashcroft fucks.
Man.
That guy was scary though.
All these people that were trying,
there was,
there was a lot of religious shit behind
it.
It'll be shit their shit in their boots
over this fucking record.
Well,
they would be dying over that record,
but he got sued.
I mean he,
he actually had to spend real money and
real stress.
Imagine the government trying to take
you out all you are as a dirty morning
radio guy and the fucking government is
trying to take you out.
You fucking probably get paranoid as
shit.
You should get paranoid.
You fucking should be paranoid.
What does it say here Jamie?
There all the different fines he had to
pay for 19 nine oh my God,
this is insane.
So it says he paid him if some of them
got paid.
I'm,
this isn't probably the initial fines
that they started as either,
but I think this is what they got
whittled down to or and read them off.
1990 he got fined $6,000 from the FCC.
1992 he got fined $105,000 from the FCC.
1992 again,
he got fined.
600,000 1993 got five find 500,000 1993
got fined.
70 3030 seven thousand four hundred
thousand in 94 200,094 holy fuck.
And then it just keeps going on.
And on and the last one right there,
495,000 in 2004 2000 and fucking and
that fucking insane.
That's during the Bush administration.
After nine 11 he got fined $1 million,
$95,000 half a million dollars in fines
for saying bad words.
Wasn't even saying bad words.
He but he didn't even say bad words.
He didn't swear.
That's what was crazy was just top its
subject matter.
The d like talking about farts or Piss
or shit or something like that.
It was so crazy though.
Such a crazy time.
If I were to say that to someone who
didn't know,
they think,
oh you mean that the 50s or the 40 this
is fucking 2000 thousand four and if he
didn't go through that,
if there wasn't this backlash from the
public finding out about it because
everybody I know that heard about it was
like what?
How are they wasting our fucking money?
Suing him over a radio show that by the
way,
has 20 million people listening to it
every morning.
It's pretty obvious that people were
enjoying this radio show.
And when they stop enjoying it,
it'll go off the air.
That's what the fucking free market is
about.
But it wasn't about that.
What it was about is controlling
somewhat cause it wasn't just his dirty
shit.
That's not what concerned them as much
as his,
his criticism of the Bush
administration,
his criticism,
political political policies and his
willingness to say whatever the fuck he
wants.
He's a dangerous guy.
He said too much power.
You thank him.
You think that's what Kinda started
podcasts?
Do you think that?
No,
I don't think that's what started
podcasts.
Um,
but I think that for him that started
the,
the journey eventually to Xm,
like he had due to serious whatever it
was at the time,
he had to,
like,
they were fucking with him constantly
all the time.
I don't think he gets enough credit for
that.
It's insanity,
man.
Yeah.
Well he's uh,
he loses,
he said he's a hero of mine that in 2040
got fine for those that cock for spink
during a product for maintaining anal
and genital hygiene.
Thompson was going after him.
He was doing those things after video
games and stuff too.
If you remember the Tennessee guy and
then he got to vis and attorney Jack
Thompson supplied,
the FCC was show transcripts.
Oh God,
listen,
I don't need,
that's not what I would I pay my
fucking,
well,
nobody did,
but it was official.
I guarantee you a lot of it was about
controlling a powerful guy.
Cause he had talked about running for
governor member,
remember?
Yeah.
But he would have got to have to
disclose how much money he made and
that's when he decided not to do it.
I wonder if he would do that now because
now everybody knows he's got a hundreds
of millions of dollars.
I wonder if it even like the gut people
run now.
They haven't disclosed shit.
Well,
trump has.
Trump says he's worth more than he
actually is.
That's what's hilarious about him.
I know,
but I'm saying has he,
have we seen the actual like,
well,
Bernie Sanders just released his tax
returns in his tax turned said that he
made less money last year than Hillary
Clinton did for one single speech.
Holly,
he made $200,000 and she's made as much
as I think to 90 for once be maybe even
in the threes for one speech.
I want to ask you to negotiate.
I'll,
I'll release my fucking return.
They're like kind of money.
I lost.
How many seats is this?
There's about 400 seats.
Okay.
I wanna like,
you know,
quarter million bucks.
What did I just told you?
There's like 400 seats and how much are
we charging these people and we got to
pay you that.
You remember
25 I think.
Memory,
I'll take that pearl jam,
fighting over,
take it prices,
making sure they don't get to be 25
bucks and now people are paying 250,000
I know.
Watch a speech.
Well that is obviously just bribery
money.
It's just bizarre that she won't release
the transcripts of the bribery money
anytime.
You don't want to release something.
It's always been good.
Imagine what she said.
You know,
they'll probably sacrificing babies and
shit and lighten owls on fire or
probably had an effigy and the war
sturgis probably all over them papers
probably.
He was probably one of the reasons why
she kept her mouth shut.
If it keeps,
it keeps his album's coming out,
I'm all for it.
Yeah.
Whatever he's gotta do,
man.
There's a lot of people that need to be
shot,
right?
Well,
yeah,
he,
no,
he's not taking out the good guys.
He's taking out,
taking out enemies of the state.
That's what's up,
dude.
He's like a showtime,
um,
drama series assassin type guy.
Oh,
maybe they'll make that show.
Imagine if that was the show.
Sturgill simpson just run around.
It was like,
do you remember that movie where the guy
from the Gong show chuck?
Oh,
come check the brains of a dangerous
mind.
I thought it was cool.
It was kind of crazy.
I was half out of it and watching that
movie in a hotel room in Vegas,
and I know,
I remember like falling asleep from
memory.
It was crazy,
but he wasn't really worried.
He thought he was worried for the
government.
It was,
but it was really weird.
It was like,
what is this?
Like I remember reading it like reading
a passage from it too.
Like it's a book.
And I remember reading the passage
going,
what is this?
Is this fake?
Was he on drugs?
Like what is this?
And I never got into it.
We were talking you speaking of that
Shit,
talking about,
you know,
First Amendment,
freedom fighters,
one of the a major hero and people don't
know about it from Kentucky Zone.
Mr Larry Flynt,
he did a lot of fun.
I don't think people realize how I'm
putting that.
There was that movie made out.
Yeah.
But I don't think,
and he's um,
and people you get laughed at when you
say Larry Flint,
flint is a hero of yours.
Cause he's like,
oh cause you love hustler and you know,
I love naked,
but it's not what I'm talking about.
No,
no.
Freedom of speech.
Matt.
He did more for freedom of speech than
probably anyone alive right now.
That you had to be as fucking crazy as
he took that shit to the supreme court
because he was fucking insane and he's
rich as fuck.
And he didn't give.
Yeah,
that was the perfect amount.
It was a perfect timing to these.
This is before porn hit the internet and
the money kind of eroded.
Yeah.
You know,
back then he was selling those
magazines.
He was rich from selling magazine.
He was going to lose everything because
of a fucking joke,
like when I was,
yeah,
he really was.
Yeah.
When I first came to la,
I remember seeing that building,
that flipped publications building.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well that's the norm is fucking huge.
I know some of the,
the of his,
I don't know,
I've met him briefly.
I know some of his family members back
in Kentucky,
but yeah,
they got,
they,
um,
it's an empire,
but also I think when he dies it'll
come.
There'll be talking about it,
you know,
they'll be,
they'll be the jokey national new shit,
but there'll be some really interesting
fucking pieces written about what he
actually did.
Cause he really changed everything.
And like this album,
literally this,
I couldn't make this album without
lyric.
I agree.
And I think that what was going on with
him at the same time as what was going
on with a Howard Stern,
there were all real similar.
I was real similar in the government was
trying to decide what people couldn't,
couldn't do and the people that didn't
get defended where the dirty ones,
dirty magazine guy,
the dirty radio guy,
for whatever reason we didn't,
they didn't get defended.
Where a journalist,
if a journalist is getting attacked like
that for revealing the truth about
something,
people would be up in arms,
the intellectuals be up in arms,
but nobody recognized that.
It's just as dangerous to tell people
that they can't jerk off to hustler as
it is to tell,
uh,
like a,
a political dissident that he can't
speak.
That's what I said at the trial.
I mean the Ed Norton Guy Played Him.
He's like,
this has nothing to do with whether you
like hustler,
right.
Has to,
it's no different than any free speech
trial anywhere.
But by the way,
if you,
you know,
if you rule against this,
that it could lead to people being
censored in all,
in all different forms.
But this is,
it took something that fall that crazy
to get it to the supreme court and
someone that fucking crazy.
It's just too problematic when you,
when you tell people what they can and
can't talk about,
it's too problematic.
You know,
if you,
if you censor someone for a specialty,
like sexual stuff,
like you censor someone for putting out
a magazine where people have sex and it,
you know,
obviously people have liked that
forever.
You do know what the,
what the actual trial was.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll repeat if it was an obscenity.
Right.
But he,
he did it.
He acted,
they had comic pieces in the magazine
and he did a piece where he said that
this one,
I may need help,
but Jerry is Jerry Falwell.
I think men,
but men find it.
Okay.
But you said that before.
I find out it was,
I want to get the guy's name right
before I fucking Jerry Falwell,
Larry's flint.
Um,
he was the big guy at the time,
right.
Jerry Falwell's guy that got caught a
hooker too,
wasn't it?
Or has Jimmy Swaggart I get them all
mixed up.
Jimmy swaggart crying on TV.
It was awesome.
You don't remember that?
Oh yeah.
I mean I used to,
I used to watch that shit all the time.
It was amazing.
It was amazing because we all knew that
he was a crazy fuck.
We knew it's not your fault.
It's a Larry flynt and uh,
just Google Larry Flynt Supreme Court.
Anyway,
the point was this preacher
had sex with his mom in and out house
and an outhouse.
Yeah.
In the magazine and me had a cartoon of
it.
Right.
And I went and saw Larry Flynt speak
cause I said,
like I said,
I'm a big fan of his.
And so they,
that the guy sued him.
Well,
it's Jerry Falwell.
Okay.
That's what I thought.
So he said Jerry Falwell had sex with
his mom and an outhouse and there was a
cartoon like a mad magazine prior to and
your follow suit them for liable,
you know,
not,
he's like,
it's obviously a fucking joke.
Like I'm,
I don't think you know,
this is fucking comedy.
And he sued him and I went to the
fucking supreme court and I went and saw
the Larry flynt talk.
And when they repeat,
when the lawyer,
this is Larry Flynt said this is what,
when he knew he knew he was going to win
the supreme court trial.
When his lawyer repeated
what the article said that his,
his mom had sex at,
Jerry Falwell had sex his in our house.
He saw the supreme,
he saw the judge just giggle for a
second and the lawyer stopped and he's
like,
and that's when he knew he had the trial
one.
Cause the whole point is you laughed
when I said it that this guy fucking his
mom out in an outhouse.
Obviously it's how are we going to have
an argument that's not comedy when all f
all you fuckers just started laughing.
He said from that point on,
he knew he was going to win.
And it was funny too,
he also said that Jerry Falwell came to
him years later and they became friends
and he wanted to go do a speak,
cause I guess he had,
you know,
maybe not watch his money.
He wanted to go do a speaking tour with
Larry Flynt.
And uh,
it's like,
I just,
you know,
I want the biggest supreme court freedom
of speech he's ever again.
He said he realized that's when they
kind of,
it's like to Jerry Falwell too.
It's all a show,
you know,
it's all,
it was just a,
it was just theater to him.
Like we,
we can go out and make some money on the
road and talk about each other.
Exactly.
And it's like,
fuck you.
That was,
I was,
I was serious about it.
And,
um,
when a funny though it was like the
party with Jerry Falwell find out what
it goes down.
But when he did become friends and
another one,
I have to look,
I,
I'm almost positive that when he died,
Larry Flynt wrote his,
uh,
maybe for the La Times.
I think Larry Flynt wrote his obituary.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
But yeah,
they became friendly or later.
But it was,
it's an interesting trial.
You should definitely check out and the
movie is sums it up,
but just you got to get into the details
of it because what they used to do at
hustler was pretty fucking crazy.
I mean besides,
you know,
really getting in there and looking
inside the post and all that shit,
they're like,
they had been in shit,
like they would do crazy like kind of x
rated mad magazine and that was the
chip.
Ironically,
they got him in trouble.
Like,
you know,
as you know that the,
it was what it was,
the,
the sex shit that they were actually
pissed.
Well yeah,
but that was what they could catch them
on because they were so preposterous.
Some of them and there was so graphic
that was,
I guess.
Yeah,
that must've been the one that was the
guy who,
uh,
this is the letter he wrote in the La
Times after he died.
How has find myself into there?
It is.
He is that,
that's his,
that's Larry Flynt Obituary for the
audit.
Coal is called the porn king and the
preacher.
Interesting is there the 1997 automatic
biography called an unseemly man.
Yeah.
He's hilarious.
He sued him for $50 million.
That's why I went to the Supreme Court.
He kept losing the case.
I lost repeatedly yet eventually won a
Supreme Gore.
Wow.
He kept losing it.
Now he's hugging me in front of millions
on the Larry King show.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That's insane.
One,
how much it cost him to fight those off
because someone suing you for $50
million.
If he lost her repeatedly,
each one of those things
it had,
luckily it was the right guy who was
crazy enough,
like you said,
and had the money to fight it because
most people would have just never
wouldn't have thought at once much less
all the way up to the supreme court.
It's funny,
man.
It's funny.
The whole thing is funny.
Yeah,
I mean the real story.
It's one of those things where the real
stories crazier in the fucking movie.
Yeah.
Well it's crazy that it's such a pivotal
moment and free speech history yet.
Like you said,
it's not something anybody ever talks
about that he actually had to go out
there like that.
I mean they were saying before they're,
they're saying snl might not exist if
that was,
if he had won that case.
Well,
look,
if he can daily showering you that shit.
If you can't,
if you can't parody public figures,
SNL can happen.
You can't do the daily show,
you know?
And we could prove that in.
Here's the way to prove it.
It's sort of a round about way,
but marijuana is still illegal in 2016
because of some bullshit propaganda that
was made in the 1930s so that momentum
carries on,
even though it doesn't make any sense.
You could still go to jail today for
growing pot.
So if you think that if Howard stern
didn't have those lawsuits,
didn't pay all that money,
didn't make this big public outright did
public outcry,
didn't have to go to Sirius satellite
radio.
If all those things didn't happen and
they won,
what did they shut him down?
What if they pulled him off the air with
Larry Larry flynt loss and never fought
it would have everything buckled down.
How long would it take care of the
Internet to happen?
How would it would have taken forward?
It have things like reddit or four chan
or these fucking uncensored blogs or
uncensored youtube content where you can
do whatever you want.
Vimeo,
all that shit podcast,
that ripple from those two guys is like
one of the most important ripples for
free speech media in 2016 and what's one
of the most important,
like pivotal moments in the history of
free speech and we're talking about
that.
It's amazing.
It's fucking crazy and crazy that we're
talking about an x ray had record that I
own on a podcast that you own.
Yeah.
This wouldn't have been fucking like
this whole world.
The whole thing wouldn't have happened.
You wouldn't be able to do that record
in one way.
Like he would've found out about it the
bigger,
even though I make fun of like those
Florida Georgia line guys,
there's a nice guys but handsome,
but we have a choice at least.
Do you think they shave their pubes?
Yes.
I think they shave each other's manscape
the shit out of that box,
right?
Oh do they got the best fucking dude?
I bet.
Think if there's like a little hair even
on the head or the Brown,
the shaft,
the shaft here,
those are weird.
I shared those immediately.
I don't like that.
Yeah.
It kind of freaks me out.
I got in a couple of freaks me out.
I like your shower.
You want to get,
it just starts happening like I have an
ear hair now didn't have ear hair when I
was young.
What if my,
my shaft,
it starts growing hairs all over it.
Nonstop.
Like a wolf man and gets every time you
shave it,
it gets fucking heroin occur.
Yeah.
It's like what did it happen on the like
[inaudible] on the head.
Oh,
that'd be crazy.
What if that's what broke like has got
dick hair on there.
Someone.
Sure.
Like some fucking big Russian dude.
Some Russian bear type character.
Some dude from Dagestan or something.
A manly man.
You've got it.
And this is,
I'm being serious here.
If you've got hair on the head of your
Dick,
you call me because I got my second
album.
I'm looking for a cover and that'll be
it.
It's called dickhead hair.
It's got,
it happened.
This,
there's some people out there,
those.
So Harry,
there's like some,
uh,
this is Russian wrestler,
I forget his name is,
but he fights in mma.
We were talking about him on the podcast
recently cause he's entering into some
grappling tournament's goddammit.
What is his name?
I've only seen him compete on youtube.
This is everywhere.
Gorilla.
He's Kinda have something.
Wasn't that Paul Simon Song hair on the
head of his Dick?
I think there was one of his best songs.
It's catchy as shit man.
I mean you sitting around your parents,
they yell at you but it's a good song.
But that was this whole the shoes.
Nevermind.
I get the different,
so you get those two songs and mixed up
all the fucking time.
Yeah,
totally.
Well if she lays it guy out there,
I don't know what the Jimmy's going to
try to find this guy but a yeah,
well it's weird that we still have hair
in weird spots on her body like that.
You're,
most of the body loses its hair in some
strange way except for the head and w
and the other weird spots like the pubes
like what the fuck is going on with the
human body and the first place.
It's so strange looking.
I remember reading an article about it.
Achy pop back in his old stooges days.
Yeah.
There's a dude,
there's the wrestler dude.
Leave the hair on this motherfucker.
He's George g kit tool live.
I mean this guy is mostly a gorilla,
but two,
it's mostly a girl.
Look at that.
I messaged her that picture on the phone
camera.
You got some hair to look at that
picture though.
Geez,
that's a God damn gorilla.
This dude's a gorilla and he also has a
Spanish bullying around his neck from
the pink tie,
believe I think he bought it from it
from Florida,
Georgia.
He took it from him.
Give it to me.
Oh,
let it break.
Nick,
you're talking about,
hey are you need,
cause I've never forget the article.
I was reading about egg in the stooges
and then he popped some,
you know,
he was on drugs whenever put glitter all
over his face and uh,
he shaved his eyebrows,
put glitter all over his face and he
went on stage and they get,
it was so fun.
The guitarist goes and that's when we
realized why you had eyebrows cause he
was sweating and all the glitter.
It was getting in his eyes.
He was like,
he's like,
oh,
so he's getting glitter in his eye ball
and his eyeball cause he shaved,
he thought would be called shave his
eyebrows.
It's like you don't think about that
shit till you get it done.
It must be brutal glitter and your
eyeballs.
Holy Shit.
He's pop poppy and do whatever.
He's probably still in their look.
Is he still alive?
Yeah,
he's touring right now.
Is he just made new record,
that guy?
I'd like to find out what he eats.
He's gotta be on a Ketogenic Diet.
He's always super,
you know,
he just,
you know Josh Ami from Queens of the
stone age?
Yes.
He just did his new record with iggy
pop.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's a new would be amazed.
It's fixed.
It's really good.
See there?
They're a great example.
Queens of Stone Age are a great example
of a band that's really hard to pin
down.
Like say what do they like?
You'd go,
Ooh man,
I don't know there they've got their own
thing going on man.
There's certain queens of the stone age
songs while you listen to like a part of
it and you go,
oh,
that's queens of the stone age.
You know what I mean?
He just know,
look at that and they are,
they are Bam,
thank you.
Pops to look and could it guys always
shredded?
I always wonder like is that just from
running around on stage?
Does he exercise?
I saw him on the stooges were giving you
and I've never seen a guy give it.
He was better than Jagger.
I thought he,
I'd never seen a god give it his all
like that.
He's still fucking rocks.
Rarely hear people talk about him.
Like is kin is like a leather bound book
that they find in a cabin.
The summon the demon that age still
given the middle thing.
Wow,
that's important.
Never give up on the middle finger.
I never get to the old.
How old is he?
I don't know.
He's got be,
he's in that ageless area where he was,
he did a lot of shit with Bowie and he's
got,
how old was bowleys?
Mid Sixties what does it say?
Jamie doesn't say,
does it say as birth watts?
Now you come on son,
go to wikipedia.
It says his fucking birth.
What does it say it there?
How dare you?
1968 what are you trying to pretend?
He's a mystery.
Not Use.
It pops right up on Google,
but you just can't assume that it's not
out there.
He's almost 70 right?
Yeah,
he's almost 70.
That's uh,
you know,
people still rocking out almost 50.
He's an animal.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
it was cool.
The Queen,
like you were saying,
like,
you know,
queen stoney's does whatever the fuck
they want.
I'm sure there was no one who was like,
there's a bunch of money for you.
You go produce until her label right now
while they're on an indie label.
Oh,
are they?
Yeah.
I wonder how much influence an indie
label has on them.
Not because they,
they can do it,
you know.
Well that's,
that's the future.
I mean,
you don't need people anymore.
And it's also the people that were
there.
They tendon exactly serve the best
interests of the work.
You know,
the people that are making these pop
songs like,
you know,
like to put together a band like my
noodle or something like that.
Why am a noodle where they come up with
that?
I kind of liked that and saying she
remembers them.
Do you remember if you remember?
But you know like okay,
like um,
milli vanilli or something like that.
This perfect example of just a creation.
I mean they weren't even singing in the
real songs.
Right.
That's just a creation and get two
handsome boy.
They were also the only ones who got
busted.
There's millions of those you think so?
There's a lot of people that got busted.
It didn't,
that did the exact same thing as they
do.
I mean,
how did they get busted?
They got busted because one of the guys,
um,
found Jesus,
something like that I think.
But he,
he came clean.
He said,
I came,
I can't go up there and performing the
songs anymore.
Wow.
And he just came clean.
I must be like a pussy and money.
I'm pretty sure we're during one of
their concerts,
their playback skipped and they go like,
well,
that happened to,
what's her face on Siren live too?
I'm looking it up right now.
I think there's video of it,
but that shit happens.
All who's the girl who who skipped on as
girl who was the sister girl with a
giant tits,
so they're trying to say that's how my
brain works by the way.
That's how your brain works.
But then now I know I was talking about
in a second.
Jessica Simpson,
right?
You give me a name.
I wouldn't have known it,
but a body.
That girl's got good Lord.
That's a perfect example of why someone
should say thick.
Seen her lately.
Is She married?
Yeah,
she's married.
Some football player.
Dude.
No disrespect,
sir.
Fuck.
But if you watch the image record,
it's,
she's already married.
Yeah.
There's other ones like that.
That's a,
that's good stock.
That's good.
Southern stock.
Yeah,
it's probably from Canada.
Whereas you're from Texas,
Texas.
That's what I'm saying,
Bro.
I knew shit.
Hey,
wait,
I think I'm doing,
am I doing decent?
There were some Texas dates up.
I hope so.
How dare you not,
well,
we're going to do the,
I do know we're not doing southeast
until they want me to wait til this.
There'll be southeast dates up there.
Well,
I mean how can we wait and they wanted
me to wait.
That one actually I listened to people
on,
they said wait until school's back in.
Cause a lot of younger,
you know all those sec schools,
you know.
Oh Kentucky,
Alabama,
Georgia.
It makes sense.
Right?
You gotta be in their town and also I
didn't want to do too many dates at one
time because my fucking voice and also I
just don't,
I'm not doing those giant,
I want to go for a long weekend.
Come home.
I can't do it.
I'm too old.
I can't just fucking long tours.
I hear exactly.
How long do you only go out for a long
couple of days at a time.
Yeah.
I don't go.
I don't do these.
Dunkin does though.
Dunkin's doing a 30 day tour right now.
He's a man.
He's a maniac.
He got a bus the whole deal.
I don't do that.
I took once.
It's not fun.
It's not enjoyable.
Was it fun?
The fee for at the beginning or know the
shows were fun,
but uh,
it's too many,
too many days where you wake up,
you stare at the ceiling,
you have no idea where you are.
He's like,
where am I fucking,
I'm not my friends.
You know,
all my friends who are musicians to do
that.
Just like,
especially now that we're getting older
and the younger even,
but it was crazy when they were young.
We were younger.
I was like,
man,
you're living the dream.
And they're just like,
I know I was supposed to be enjoying
this,
but it's just not fucking,
one thing that helps is to do it with
people you really like.
That helps a lot.
There's,
there's lots of stuff that helps,
but they're still,
you know,
when you're a kid you're just like,
oh,
getting fucked up,
getting pussy,
playing rock and roll or country,
whatever it is.
It sounds like the ultimate life.
And so these people have not having fun
doing it.
They also should get a fucking real job.
And remember what it's like to have to
go somewhere every morning.
Oh,
Dell.
Yeah.
And work all day for some of it sucks.
It's just easy to get complacent.
Oh,
it's easy to not feel Grad.
I used to spend,
I used to spend my summers as a farm
hand bag and Kentucky.
Yeah.
And I'm kind of farms,
little mostly horse,
Lexington,
and there's a lot of like rich fucks who
just by these giant,
they're not like really working farms.
They're just like,
they build themselves up on Derby type
shit.
Yeah.
They just like,
you forget with horse racing,
it's one of the only sports where the
owner is like the main guy.
So you can,
I've made billions.
I've always loved horses.
Like you can win when the person,
they put it on the screen.
When the horse went to Kentucky,
Derby is the owner.
Right.
So you can,
you can buy yourself into it.
You're like,
oh,
I've always loved horror.
Kentucky Derby,
the owners,
the writer.
Not the writing on the jockey,
but I'm saying you don't know the
jockeys.
You know,
you know who the fucking owner is.
Isn't,
that is weird,
right?
Or,
you know,
the real,
I mean,
but he's not on the horse,
but he's winning and he didn't train it.
He hasn't tried to do a damn thing.
They showed the trainer,
they showed the jockeys shut the horse,
but the real person,
they interviewed the owner.
So you buy a big farm in Kentucky has
some dumb ass like me,
like we'd eat or whatever.
Why don't you ever read the Kentucky
Derby is decadent and dupre.
Oh,
I fucking,
yeah.
A hunter,
s Thompson,
other Kentucky guy who was a hero of
mine.
Best.
Who's the best?
And that's what a barbarian,
he was fucking insane.
He was the best.
And there's some pieces that he wrote to
his day.
I'll,
I'll read,
I'll go fucking Christ.
I still think,
um,
uh,
you know,
fear and loathing is one of my favorite
books of all time.
Fear and loathing is outstanding.
And you remember when they did that
thing where Johnny Depp read the passage
that he talked about like the,
the change that was coming in the 1970s
and how it all pulled back and that he
saw it all happen.
I mean he was the perfect guy to
capture,
oh,
in the movie,
the movie,
it was fucking great.
Johnny Depp was the perfect guy.
But I mean hunter was the perfect guy to
capture because he had been in the 60s
and Berkeley during the acid times and
you know,
the Timothy leary and the merry
pranksters and all that shit.
He had been with those guys and the Ken
Keyes.
And then when it all pulled away and
everybody just got locked up and went to
jail and the war on drugs and all the
things happen,
he saw this death of the American dream
and he put it so eloquently and then
Johnny Depp pretending to be him did it
for a scene in that movie.
And it's fucking sensational wonder too
if it's cause di Johnny Depp's also from
Kentucky,
I want,
it's also a good friend of his,
they were friends and new,
if you're starting from the same place
and your friends,
it Kinda probably seeps into you a
little bit,
but certainly helps.
And Johnny stayed with him like when he
was doing that movie,
he stayed with them for a long time.
He lived with them.
But that book is a perfect example of
like real,
just first of all,
laugh out loud.
Funny Shit,
the funniest shit you've ever read.
Dylan's up.
But so fucking he can read,
he goes deep emotionally.
You forget,
he goes fucking deep and that it is a
great book.
That's his well between that and
there's,
there's a few things that he wrote,
like small pieces that he wrote to that
just go,
there were some pieces right before he
died that he wrote,
I think it was on espn website that were
like kind of predicted the whole world
that was going to happen.
That was when after nine 11 or check out
those articles man.
Cause it was he,
um,
he,
it was almost like he checked out
because he knew what was going to
happen.
Yeah.
He saw it.
Well,
he was also like a serious alcoholic to
the point where when he was almost dead,
you couldn't even understand them
anymore.
He would do shows.
He would do like,
um,
Conan or not Conan.
He would,
yeah,
he did.
Conan.
He did Koni on,
actually it was one of the worst where
they went out shooting.
They went to woody creek and they went
shooting and hunter was fucking hammered
the entire time,
the shooting guns in Colorado and you
literally can't understand a fucking
word he's saying he would get up and
just get fucked up all fucking day.
He was so fucked up though,
that it was starting.
It was like he had poisoned his brain.
Yeah,
that's,
you know what I mean?
Like he,
he had also been on ceres pain pills
because he had hip replacements.
I think he bought both of his hips went
bad and back then,
dude,
when they were doing hiphop payslips
today ain't like today.
Like those hips weren't so good.
Like today.
They've got it down pretty good.
Where I've,
I've had some friends that got hip
replacements and they don't feel any
pain.
It's amazing.
It's just they've placed this,
this socket,
not official soccer.
He used to be that used to be the old
thing.
It's like,
yeah,
major surgery.
You don't hear much.
Why?
Dude Graham Hancock was in here six
weeks after he got a hip replacement and
he was walking without a limp and I was
like,
how is that fucking possible?
And he's like,
it's crazy.
And Graham was like in his sixties right
holes.
Graham,
I think he's like maybe 60 at the very
least.
He's in his late fifties and he got a
hip replacement.
I want an old people used to get,
you know,
had to get hip replaced.
It's like how you do,
they were about to check out.
Yeah man now.
And it was an ugly,
ugly,
ugly operation.
When they did it,
they'd saw off your fucking femur and
screw a bolt in there and it's like
there was a raw that had to go deep in
your bones and your bonus.
A takeover that rod and hole.
How Old Graham?
65 so he's probably 62 or 63 he goes hip
replace place.
Then six weeks later he's walking
without a limp.
It's crazy.
It's all,
I mean,
yeah,
they're fucking fee.
I think buddy's a Jujitsu guy.
He's in his thirties he got both his
hips were placed in his thirties and
that's just from just train.
How long ago would that,
would that surgery take you out and 10
years ago.
Like you couldn't even do it right?
Yeah.
10 years ago you'd be done and
everything after that you'd be done,
you'd be fucked.
You being like real problem.
Let's look at,
cause I watched as any Kentucky and I
watch a lot of basketball.
They've got Paul George.
Is he the guy I'm thinking about who he,
he broke his leg,
something awful last.
It was like they were like,
his career was over and I think he had
like a good seat.
He did well this season.
Like he just,
it was as if nothing had happened.
It's fucking bone came out of his
fucking leg and it was a dangerous too.
And he uh,
didn't,
he isn't extra of it during team USA.
I can't look at it.
Close your eyes.
Oh my God.
He's back now.
All Star,
all star.
And this is not,
this is name five.
This is last year.
I was like a couple of years ago and
he's an all star is here.
That's incredible.
It's like just snapped.
But now you know,
they have all the,
this way healing things.
They use all sorts of different methods
to accelerate healing.
They just keep,
they're getting so good at it.
Doctors are just fucking unbelievable at
it now.
It's,
it's incredible time to be injured and
if you get injured now they just,
they fix you in a way that just wasn't
available.
Like I have to replaced acs,
but I have a buddy of mine,
my friend Steve who was on the ski team,
the US ski team in the 1980s and he's a
badass skier in the 1980s and his knees
are devastated.
He's had,
and I would actually have to call him to
confirm this,
but I know he's had more than 20 knee
surgeries after.
How do you fucking go through an animal?
He doesn't give a fuck.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
He's in his sixties and still fights.
He still goes to gym and spars.
It's thinking about competing.
It's almost like going to the fucking
dentist at that point or getting a
haircut or something.
He's just an animal.
This guy is just,
there's certain people that like pain is
a non factor to [inaudible] movement.
What does that,
that's the well look at it.
Poking out of the skin right there.
Holy that the local guy.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's hardcore.
Do you know how hardcore that is?
Yeah.
I felt for the guy and I fucking hate
little so that that means it's serious
shit that is serious.
It looks like a tour through the skin
and all the muscle and everything too.
Like that is a serious trauma that
happened.
It was live on television.
They were worried about that.
Um,
with uh,
the octagon,
they're worried about that ever
happening.
You know,
only breaks we've seen on legs and arms
have been non compound breaks.
But I think when it happens,
like that guy just had it,
it becomes more problematic because when
it breaks the skin,
you have all this possibility for
infection that exist.
It gets real bad.
Well I remember,
uh,
them really fast going over there with a
towel and covering it up cause it was on
live TV and they covered it up.
So like,
oh that's cause they didn't want people
to see it probably.
Right.
No,
that's what I'm saying.
It's like the first,
it's,
we live in a world where the first
reaction was get this shit off TV.
But yeah.
Why not go to fucking commercial?
Wasn't it funny man that like movies,
there's every big action movie that you
go to Wa watch somebody die.
Every one of them.
Yeah.
Like it's no big deal.
But people,
fuck,
it becomes a disgrace.
It's a real problem.
It's a disaster.
Like if you have to remember that Brown
bunny movie where Vincent,
what the flux is,
Miss Gallo.
Yeah.
He had a movie where the chloe's
Virginia.
Did she fucking suck his Dick in the
movie?
It's already,
and I saw it.
Yeah.
That's the only reason why I started to,
yeah,
it seemed like that whole movie was just
like getting to the blowjob.
Like I was like,
blah,
blah blah.
Let's get,
let's cut the walk to the scene.
If I can go home and get on a fucking
website in two seconds and see all that
shit.
Well I think his idea was why can't we
have a real sex scene?
Like if you can have like people kissing
for real and rubbing each other for real
and,
but you know intellectually that they're
not actually having sex,
but it's supposed to be a sex scene.
So if you have these two people,
Vincent Gallo and chloe's suffocating
doing and that are adults and they
agree,
they agree like I think you're
attractive or I'm willing to do this or
I think it'd be cool to do this in the
film.
I want to actually give you head in this
movie.
Why is that bad?
So it was real.
It was 100% really came on her face and
everything.
Like she sucked his dick like a champ.
Outstanding.
It just put boat.
It's weird that it be like we all,
everybody I assume has gotten their Dick
sock.
I assume.
If you haven't,
I feel so bad for you.
If you haven't put out a fucking record,
let my man nonstop.
That's what happens.
It's nonstop.
Dick Second.
I can't even put,
I wish I had fucking two dicks right
now.
What'd you did that video for?
A eating pussy and sucking dick or even
pussy and kicking ass.
Sandik doesn't come into that.
That comes through to the end.
Um,
that audience,
what was going on there?
Did they have the ideal?
It's told,
but because I got kind of thrown,
they told just an audience that you're
going to to get here,
like you're just going to watch a real
country guy just in country.
I didn't know that they had told them
that,
but there was only like 15 people in
there.
There's,
I feel like there was a more like 150,
a hundred and,
and so they were just waiting for a
country song,
which I find out later.
And then when I got to even the eating
pussy,
they,
their faces fucking dropped.
I knew I was and this is not my best
gig.
And then I was like,
we got to get to the,
you know,
the Dick Suck,
which is going to ramp it up a notch.
And uh,
then I think a couple people walked out
and like weren't too happy.
But I'll tell you what it was.
It's one for the ages.
It's certainly,
you've got the shit out there.
I was amazing.
Nobody yelled anything out like nobody
told you to stop.
Well I think they're,
they were,
someone told me that they were at,
I think they were extra,
so I think they probably lost.
Oh you probably would have knocked.
Got Cause I didn't know I was walking
into like a fucking allergy kind of
thing.
Oh that's fine.
I'm just there to play this fucking
dirty country song.
Oh that's funny.
So they just hired some country looking
people?
No,
I think they hired people who said they
were fans of country music.
Okay.
And then they said,
do you want to be a part of a music
video?
Just have a seat.
Yeah.
Cause you could see like there's a guy
here,
punch plate.
Jamie put what's the,
what's the video?
It's called a eating pussy and kicking
ass
and I'll play him the place at least the
second from the one on the album.
Okay.
But the one I want to watch,
the one words the from the bench show.
What was the falling out with Ben?
He just fucking out.
He didn't even pay me for that.
Really?
I play by play.
He didn't pay me for the music or even
the appearance.
That's so rude.
But look,
you have the last laugh here.
Yes.
What's he doing now?
These people in the audience
any better.
I like the American flag and I just got
off the,
I didn't have a beer at the time,
so then they're like my boss man.
I didn't want to,
I was scared about
fucking
pussy and kicked his ass
pussy kicking a house,
eating pussy and kicking ass,
eating pussy,
kicking a house,
eat pussy.
And these people are just not
responding.
They don't and that's what I do.
I don't know what to do with you.
The lady in the night and eat a lot of
pussy.
Then I get into a fight
Thursday night I was feeling pretty
good.
I was walking down the boulevard,
Hollywood.
See this young girl,
she's smiling at me.
So I took it back to my hotel and paid
the beans,
the golf skirt.
I knew that something was wrong where
they're supposed to be a pussy.
This girl had well
keep killing a little bit.
Anyway,
Dick and then uh,
kicked his ass,
sucking Dick,
sucking Dick and kicking ass,
eating pussy,
sucking Dick and kicking it out.
Plus he sucking Dick at kick Eaton
fucking Dick and kicking ass.
I love that.
A little kid there.
Um,
they get mad at you after that was over?
No,
cause I just went back to this fucking
trailer.
I never even talked to him again.
Can you go to the,
is it the version of it?
I want you to hear how a great fucking
producer yet.
Okay.
Go to the,
the dose.
There's another version of that,
Jamie.
That's just the album.
You just see the cover photo and then
you hear the music.
Same Song.
Here we go folks.
Here's the producer produced version of
it.
Fuck yeah.
More federal money.
Yeah.
Is this Good
Friday night and just got old for my
mall smile
so I have to work on with his last pool.
Seeing design.
Dude,
I'm fucking 12 years old.
I really,
that's what happened.
We don't censor yourself.
You become a kid again.
You know,
I'm always like this.
This is my kind of music.
A lot.
It's bigger.
One owner.
That is so ridiculous.
I want to hear the second part about
sucking Dick Ass.
Let's keep it going.
How is this version front long.
Hey,
fast forward to the second day.
Try to find this Dick Second power play
studio.
You kind of,
what is it more versus in this one?
Yeah,
you want a job?
Okay.
Oh man,
I went on forever.
Once your money you just keep playing.
So you had a bunch of these and this
one,
not just two.
I liked that you went right from one to
the next in front of those people who
are self walking on Broadway.
Young girls.
She smiling back to Sam
took up.
Most of the girl had to hear the fan
actually get pissed.
How studio inside paint.
Anyway,
Dick and Leanna kick design.
That's a drummer.
How good does his voice sound?
Come on,
but
I'm over here sweating.
Goddamn it.
Fucking play mode.
Fire.
Where'd everybody go?
They didn't.
How was going there?
Is it
the same thing?
Cause they hadn't watched that clip.
They know where I was going,
but it was just songs sit on my face.
That's the one that people keep her.
So they literally didn't know where
you're going with that song.
Well,
they knew they wreck I people,
no,
there's no record.
I mean,
I mean the people you were doing it
with.
I told the producer like,
don't tell keen pussy kicking ass and
don't tell him about the,
Oh don't tell you the other artists
don't tell the drummer guitar player and
the Bass player that it's going to go to
the second date cause they hadn't seen
the clip.
So they love,
they love in the song and they still
like,
you know,
they still love it.
But you know,
it'd be funny to,
uh,
um,
I thought I'd be flying to fuck with
that because I was just like fucking
with people,
you know.
And uh,
I don't know about that.
They didn't even get high,
uh,
sit on my face.
Oh yeah.
That's a new one.
People are always be Chris.
Let's now fucking co this is on some
country shit.
You lose a few,
you get sag,
but tonight it'll cause Margolis.
Beggars can't be choosy.
Maher starts to
dicking around.
Mama get sticky and it has some good
country shit.
You know,
you tell me that.
You told me
better country music are there now.
Right there.
The music is good.
Well that's,
we got the best fucking record out there
right now.
I'm telling you.
Well what's good is it like the,
the sounds are good.
Like I liked the way it starts.
It's like,
it's cool.
Like I said,
best producer,
best players in Nashville doing this and
they had a fucking blessed,
I mean,
like I said,
it's going to,
I'm going to get banned from music row,
but I don't get it.
Oh,
who cares?
You know Dick dead.
They're all dead in the water.
You could sell records anymore.
Nobody sells records.
You sell things on Itunes,
nobody's buying records and you and ma,
what percentage of records actually get
bought?
How many people have a CD in their house
anymore?
It's nones.
It's all gone.
I don't even know how to get the CD on
him.
I fucking falling.
No,
I haven't.
I've had two cars in a row where at a
three year lease where I'd never put a
single fucking thing in the CD holder
here,
the little cd slot,
it's in two fucking cars in a row,
two leases,
three t,
three year leases.
So I haven't used a CD in six years.
At least I wanna hear something funny.
So like you're saying,
it's about selling the other shit.
So we go selling them on itunes.
People buy them on
going about like March.
So we have this,
that shirt I gave you with the logo on
it and a bunch of people were kept
emailing me to uh,
that they,
I wish I had an example of it,
but then they kept email by it
can email me that we don't have fat fuck
sizes.
That was what their little work.
I get that at [inaudible] dot com yeah,
people always get mad.
So I go,
I called the march people and I go make
some fat fuck sizes.
No,
like you mean like double x?
Like oh yeah,
yeah.
He will also underneath and red letters.
I want it to say fat fuck,
size under the logo.
And they're like,
seriously?
It's like,
yeah,
if you're fat,
fuck you.
You know,
you gotta we can't keep them in stock.
You can buy a wheel or walk on my left
on my fucking whatever.
Merge store.
You can buy a wheel marker.
Not only can you buy fat folks,
if you're a fat fuck,
you can't buy the regular shirt.
You have to lose the weight or you got
to buy a fat book size every double xl.
Triple xl says fet books as big red
letters and beautiful.
And like I said,
we can't make him start.
I bet a lot of girls are sleeping.
I'm like nineties.
Yeah,
it's,
I mean,
you should see one girl send me a
picture of her in the shirt.
It goes to her fuck.
You know,
it's like,
uh,
she put a belt around it and go,
you know,
go out for the night.
Like it's a like a dress.
So you were about that far away from
quitting music.
There it is.
Fat Fuck,
size only 20 bucks.
That's a good deal,
dude.
You were like that,
that close to quitting music and now,
no.
Yeah,
no,
it was,
this was,
here's this is it,
this is my party song.
I'm gonna play my final show and we're
going to fucking,
I'm going to go back to Kentucky,
live on,
you know,
farm,
try to,
you know,
had x and all that kind of bullshit.
And I was like,
this was my parting gift has,
you know,
like a,
like a game show or something.
And then I got a call,
like,
actually it was before it came out.
They're like,
we,
we think it's going to sell.
And I just met my manager a fucking
piece of shit.
Dumb ass.
But he's like,
and he was about to go on and move onto
to others,
find other jobs.
So,
and then it's,
it's,
you go into the studio not giving a
shit,
putting out an album about how fucking
shitty your life is and how everything's
gone to shit and not giving a shit what
people think.
This is the one that's gonna work,
you know?
So we call,
he's like,
you're,
you know,
it's like,
like I said,
we had bunch of Presales to like I guess
on itunes you can buy before it comes
out.
Cause we,
so we knew before that week,
they're like the Presales,
like you're not the number.
He my people called Amazon and itunes to
thinking there was a mistake on both of
them are like,
how can,
cause we only put out a couple of
[inaudible] songs on youtube.
How's it sound?
This fucking much like as a decimal
point in the wrong place.
And Amazon asked for a new shipment.
We didn't even have the fucking seat.
We had to go print more.
We made like a thousand or something.
Are you going to do another one?
Fuck yeah,
you gotta keep going.
No,
I was a thing as I was going to quit now
it's like fuck that.
You know.
Well this seems like it'd be fun to
write this shit too.
Well that's why I did it.
Well that's the whole point is making
music and writing songs is supposed to
be fun.
And when you write from the heart and
you write from without censoring
yourself,
the unfun part is trying to fit that,
the nasty
thoughts into something clean.
That's where it becomes on fun.
Do you think you're going to do a
musical video for which one are you?
Queer is going to suck my dick.
Um,
I'd like to,
we're talking to,
I'm a Spielberg about it right now.
He wants to do it.
It's just a budget issue.
Where do you want to do it?
What?
California?
I wouldn't do it.
And like Santa Monica,
it's up to him.
I think,
you know,
maybe I'd love to do it in Europe
somewhere so we're in Europe would be
good.
Yeah.
Like really?
You're all gay guys.
Yeah,
I want to do it.
You know,
that's the right way.
That's a song you don't take.
You don't take that shit lightly.
Do it the right way.
You don't do it.
There are different kinds of gay people
in Europe,
right?
What do you mean like wear better
clothes?
I felt like,
I mean a higher class quaffed yeah,
probably.
I don't know.
The ones they wear makeup there where
they have their hair done.
Right.
We'll do it in here.
Yeah.
I'm all about,
you know,
thing.
And I remember Bruno.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Ali G.
Um,
I was a fucking funny movie.
Allergies the past.
I heard his new movie,
like people didn't dig it.
I saw it.
Did you like it?
It was pretty fun.
I mean,
it was,
it was funny.
Yeah.
But it was,
it was,
the problem is when you compare it to
the shitty does,
you know,
you can't compare a mood.
It's like the other ship wasn't a movie.
This is like,
it's just a real,
it was a funny,
it was dirty,
you know,
it's,
but it's,
uh,
it's actual drama comedy,
you know,
it's like a comedy.
Yeah.
But film school,
it wasn't like,
it wasn't like you're living it,
you know,
like Bora.
Yeah.
I think I can work.
It was so ridiculously funny.
Thoughts.
It's a problem because it's so rigid and
he'd have a really hard time doing that
again,
it's almost like to do that he's got,
is not do it for years.
And then people forget about it and then
go back in and do it again.
He uh,
he did something at the Oscars this
year.
He would like presented an award and I
guess he had to agree to not do any sort
of thing.
He was just coming in itself,
just snuck in his character.
We're using his wife.
Okay.
Funny bit funny.
Somewhat.
If you've seen this clip,
someone showed me this was fucking,
my brother actually showed it to me.
He did got this Charlie Chaplin Award.
Did you see that thing?
It's Charlie Chaplin Award.
It was a year,
a few years.
A couple of years ago.
He,
they gave him this award for um,
you know Camille is like a Charlie
Chaplin Award for like greatness and
comedy or something.
And he did this bit,
I don't want to give it away if you
haven't seen it,
but it's fucking,
it was the funniest fucking thing I
seen.
You find that.
Yeah.
Can we watch it?
And I don't know if we could play it on
out.
It's got a little over 4 million will
get pulled over and look it up.
It's on the beach.
Well,
tell people,
what is the title of the video against
Sasha?
Baron Cohen Kills Presenter and accepts
award extended.
I guess it just [inaudible] the,
uh,
awards on BBC America.
Can I tell you what happened or do I
ruin it for him?
He probably ruin it for everybody.
Well,
do what you want to do,
man.
I don't want to check out the video.
It's really fun.
Okay,
I'll definitely check it out.
This is a good time for crazy shit.
You know,
this is the perfect,
I had to come out with this album.
What I say every,
every day is the new best day for this
crazy shit because everyday people give
less of a fuck.
And cause,
I mean,
the honest truth is,
you know,
I met the producer and I talked to
sturge on.
I said,
you know,
I asked about that.
You know,
cause he's the only guy I knew who knew,
who knew Dave.
I go
and I go,
what?
What's,
you know,
is he cool?
He goes,
he don't give a fuck
hired right there.
You know,
like don't get that's in these nowadays.
That's an ultimate compliment.
You can give me about anyone.
And he meant he meant as a co as a
compliment too.
And so those are the people that you
want to hang out with.
All I care about is people who,
you know,
I'm sure your audience knows,
but there's people out there who think
that the phrase don't give a fuck is a
Nigga.
You know,
like I don't care.
I care too much that needs someone who
doesn't care about the other shit.
It's changing.
You know the phrase is changing now.
It's a,
it's a different thing now.
Like not giving a fuck was like you're
an idiot or a loser.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He's a dummy.
But now it's like I don't give a fuck
gibbon now.
Yeah,
exactly.
Listen,
I can get banned from Nashville.
I could give it,
but I don't give a fuck cause I'm making
the record I want to make.
Well it's just amazing that that's how
it worked out.
You know,
that this thing's taken off because he
just said fuck it.
Let's just go all in.
And I was like,
I said,
this is like the perfect time to person
and I hate to bring it back to you,
but I'm here.
But you didn't do the podcast to get
listeners.
You just want something you wanted to
do.
Just do it for fun.
You did it for fun.
I did this record.
I was just like,
I want to do it for fun.
I don't when things are good man,
when you,
when you actually enjoy him,
like that shit is making me laugh.
Even the actually the opposite,
which is I assume no one's going to ever
hear this,
so I'm just going to go fucking all out.
So actually got,
it's kind of not scared,
but like when it went,
it debut,
like I said,
number nine on the billboard,
country charts,
outselling all the big boys.
I'm like,
Holy Fuck,
what the fuck do I do now?
Cause then you got to double down and
make it even go even crazier.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
And then that's when,
because then they're like,
you know,
you're real fucking is it as he walked
at like,
uh,
he talk it.
So I get on my twitter and I fucking rip
on Nashville,
rip on the music business,
rip on all these fuckers and that's how
you get in band.
And I'm getting banned,
but I come go.
So these Florida Georgia line guys,
they got mad at you.
They,
they blocked,
they blocked.
Uh,
there's a new guy,
I don't even remember his name.
He blocked me too.
I've got blocked by him.
So who's Meghan?
Meghan trainor.
Is that her name?
[inaudible] she's in a country.
She's all about that bass.
She blocked her.
She fuck all I said,
I just,
he always promoted tweets that are on
your fucking thing,
right?
I said get this shit off my page and
then
there's not much to block me.
Promoted tweets are sneaky's fuck aren't
I know,
but it said promoted tweets.
So I go,
I seen this fucking tweet 18 times a
day.
I get it.
She got a new fucking album.
Um,
I don't mind like uh,
instagram promoted instagram thing cause
I feel like,
ah,
go ahead.
Well My,
I'm getting it all for free.
We're getting it all.
You got to get money out of this
somehow.
No,
no.
I listen,
I was,
I've done,
I don't think I did a promoted tweet on
twitter,
but I've done on facebook and he,
and like half the comments are like,
get this shit.
It's the same thing as me,
but I don't block them.
I've got to say,
you're pretty sure you're worried here.
Speaking of Instagram,
Bam,
Bam.
Yeah,
I got to do it too.
Hold on.
How do I do this shit?
They ain't know how to do it.
And we gotta get,
we gotta go take a picture together and
I'll do all that.
I just wanted to get a picture of you in
the moment.
That's my new thing.
Let's get someone in the middle of the
podcast.
No posing before the podcast.
Actually this conversation is going
down,
right Jamie?
Yeah.
That's why we started doing the pictures
for the podcast and we used to have this
pose,
which I was,
felt was weird.
I was like,
why don't we just have one what in the
middle of us talking and use that and
that way you could see what a mess this
place is to cause chaos to my left here
you got a picture
and can,
can I am
kicking that?
I'm,
if I can't,
that's a catchy goddamn song.
He can put some bitches.
The catchiest song.
I disagree.
I'm telling you eat pussy checking the
font of it makes me sing all day long.
I seen that shit all the time.
I eat and puts it kick kicking house.
Um,
different strokes to everyone's got
different favorites.
Yes.
Different strokes for different folks.
It's funny too cause do you never like
okay
when you make a record he was like
I didn't,
I thought about not putting that song
on.
I was like people have heard it on that
other show four.
I was probably not going to put her on
the record.
And that's one of the people,
you know,
there was a couple of songs at the ones
that people liked the most were the ones
I was like,
I don't know if I want to recall.
It probably happens in comedy too.
Like I don't know if this jokes,
it's kind of like a throwaway joke and
it ends up being getting the biggest
fucking life for the show.
You'd never know when you actually write
something out.
That's what's funny.
You know,
you write things out and you go,
man,
this part don't work that good.
And that part gets,
is huge.
Fucking laugh and you're like,
oh,
it's weird.
It's weird when people like you know,
some songs,
I mean it's gotta be just some songs
that you don't think are your best songs
and people pull you aside.
Like what sturgeon,
they say you can have the crown song.
Yeah,
he fucking hates that.
Sorry man.
I'm telling you dude,
I listen to that song.
All the fun.
I love that song is one of my all time
favorite songs and he doesn't even like
it happens all the time.
Yeah.
I mean like well the title track Redneck
Shit.
I tried to talk,
he finally talked me into recording
cause my demo,
you know cause it's weird because it's
your song.
So when someone's telling you that your
song is,
it's like a,
and you're telling them it's not.
It's like a weird argument.
You're arguing about yourself.
I go,
let's try it.
And it was so good that I put it the
title track first track on the record,
you know like he was right.
You know you,
that's why you need that second voice.
Sometimes that shit is a good one too.
It's like a good introduction song to
what you're doing and having that be the
first song of smart because if someone
listens to that then they'll get hooked
and then,
and then by the time they get to eat and
pussy kicking ass,
they're already in.
Well that's what I've noticed.
If you look on itunes later,
like every fucking country record on
itunes,
it's all five stars because everyone who
buys it on the ratings,
they all buy it.
They know what they're getting,
they love it.
I'm the only one on there,
like literally it's five stars,
one star or five stars.
And I
promise,
cause it's like this is not what country
means.
You're supposed to be,
you can't curse in country.
And,
and I'm telling you right now,
those one star fuckers are selling my
album way more than the five star cars.
They're telling what was like from that
private parts,
you know,
it's like the f I'm paraphrasing,
but the five star people are telling
three friends,
the one start,
people are telling 20 friends,
you know,
and they're the ones getting the word
out because I don't know why they think
it's so no one I love,
I love country music so much,
you know,
and those are my heroes so much that I
hate to see what's happening to it.
And then those fuckers who listened to
this dog shit,
fucking pop rap garbage are yelling at
me that I'm disrespecting country music.
I go,
this is fucking country music.
You know,
if you don't like I can,
if you don't like the word fuck or shit,
you know that's fine.
That's has nothing to do with what I'm
doing.
But if you think that it's legit because
I'm cursing or talking about fucking
sucking dicks.
Yeah.
Or like there's family trees,
a song about a girl that I liked your
sister better but then you like you do
is you just add to,
you know,
it's like a dating this girl but I want
to fuck her sister.
But then of course I take it a step
further.
You know what?
Fuck you,
I'd rather fuck your uncle and your
fucking dead.
You Lick Your fucking dad's ball,
you know,
and then you go crazy and it's like,
Geez,
you're not,
you don't really want to do that,
but just funny to think about it.
Then you go over toward the song and of
course you know the players and I was
like,
what the fuck are you saying that?
But it does make the point.
I mean it's a song on here called can't
fuck you off my mind.
How many?
Like it's just like,
it's just a,
can't drink you off my mind with they
used to say,
and now it's like you've been through
that.
Everyone,
everyone's had a heartbreak,
but you know,
and you try to fuck some other girls to
get over it and you're,
all you're doing is thinking about the
first girl I tried to fuck a bunch of
girls and it never works it to know what
else could works.
You got to fuck the right girls.
Well I fucked the wrong ones,
but you fucked the right ones.
You don't even care about the other one.
Well you,
but don't you think that's something
people can relate to at the very least.
So they can't sing about that.
And the other thing too is one
mainstream press,
especially except for a few places
pretty much like there's no reviews of
it really anywhere.
But one guy wrote a review.
I thought it was pretty interesting.
He actually used that [inaudible]
Florida Georgia line as an example.
Um,
I wish I could remember who it was.
It might've been a blog called state and
country music.
I think it's what it was.
And they use an example of a floor of
Georgia line lyric that was like in,
you were talking about sticking my pink
and your stride was like kind of
talking.
He was saying the article about how like
these mainstream guys who talked this
dirty shit but co sugarcoat it and
little girls are hearing it.
What did they say?
I don't know exactly what,
I don't know the actual lyric but it was
kind of gross.
But that they do that to have it
censored.
Kevin,
not to have it be played on the radio so
they can make money.
So what I'm doing as much better,
because I'm saying this is for adults,
the CD,
I mean the CD and the online has the
sticker on it.
Adults,
you know,
parents,
little visor
don't yell at them.
They're the ones trying to give it to
kids.
This is for adults.
I'm saying that since the fucking
weekend.
Don't worry about the criticism,
but also I'm happy.
I'm just happy you're doing it.
And he was,
he was saying in a positive way,
by the way,
but I liked the belt buckle too,
by the way.
She saw those.
Yeah.
Well,
do you think I fucking lost it?
People would buy those.
You should have that Wheeler Walker
bellport new.
What's cool.
Tell me,
talk about that shirt too.
Is that just a single dubby right?
Well,
yeah,
they didn't,
they,
I want to make,
I want to make a wwe junior.
Well,
you need to,
uh,
a big heart or something.
Yeah.
I need to are,
um,
that she,
that shirt was made for me by the,
uh,
in California by the nudies t you
remember nudies this old nudie suits
that they used to wear in the 60s.
You guys remember that duties,
it sounds like.
Does this guy,
I think he was,
I think it's Ralph annuity.
He still,
he made the suits that you would see in
the old western movies,
how you spell it and you die like a
Nudie magazine.
Yeah.
And he would,
uh,
make these nudie suits at like buck
owens and people like that.
Well,
what happened was they used to be in the
old westerns,
um,
these crazy suits and people like elvis
or Johnny Cash used to watch those
westerns.
They go,
they started calling this guy there.
Orbison.
Yeah.
What's his name is
Ralph annuity.
So,
so these,
these people like elvis or Johnny Cash,
Hank Williams,
even they would call,
they're like,
I want a suit.
Like they will warren,
you know,
whatever.
Western movie.
And then he started making clothes for
musicians.
Dolly Parton's there.
Who's that dude right there?
Barry Klein,
who's barely climb that?
Patsy cline's dad.
I Dunno,
there's grand and back there.
Um,
anyway,
but I guess his grant or somebody kept
it going and I,
they,
they reopened in La for a little,
I think they're back out of business.
I didn't,
I'm not sure,
but that's an actual annuity.
A shirt wow.
Made for me at the fucking Taylor.
And everything costs more than a fucking
record.
That's amazing.
Oh yeah,
there it is.
I love shit like that.
Nudies Rodeo.
Taylor's,
Hollywood,
California with the credit side too.
Yeah.
So those are still around.
Well I think they're bringing it back.
Yeah.
I have tee shirts that go and read Ed
Hardy on yet they're going to have
glitter.
It's going to be glitter on those
fucking tee.
But anyway,
back called the tailor and they made me
that.
I just wanted that.
I wanted that label on the back of the
Nudie.
That's pretty cool.
I love things like that.
You find out.
I think they got it.
They got a museum.
Yeah,
it was cool cause I just looked it up
like what I did was I was,
that's what's great about the Internet
because I looked it up.
I was like,
it's still kind of shirt I want for my
record coat.
And then I,
oh,
I want annuity shirt,
I look it up,
I'll send,
I see their website and I look at it and
you can get one made.
But you know,
it's just that.
It's just that I don't want it one lock
it.
I just want,
I want hit.
No,
that's cool.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
He should do that.
But he used to like soup up.
Like Elvis has cars and shit.
Really?
Yeah.
There's nudies did a bunch of car shit
where you had elvis had a souped up car.
Yeah,
but he had what they did though.
Suits.
They would do what to car.
It's like horns coming out of it and
glitter and all that.
Fuck yeah.
That's hilarious.
Look at this thing.
So there's that.
That's a famous,
that's that famous elvis suit.
He made it.
He made elvis a gold shiny suit.
Yeah.
What is the one with the car though?
Go back to that car.
That's hilarious.
It's Elvis had you imagine driving that
Cadillac?
It was on Elvis.
Who said that?
The nudie car,
it might be his,
he was at his car.
I don't know.
Maybe it was so he designed a thing.
Didn't go,
there's a museum around here somewhere
you can go to chicken out.
I wonder if that was his,
but that that's why is your a rifle look
at,
there's a rifle back there.
He'll how to put it was a rifle.
Goose cattle car.
Two rifles on the sides,
but one of them that's in like a firing
position to shoot at people behind you.
Well,
when I make,
what the fuck is that man?
If your fans,
hey,
I'll make a promise right here.
If I get to number one,
I'm wearing that.
I'm wearing a nudie suit nonstop for a
fucking week.
A whole week.
I should,
I take it back a year,
a year,
a year.
I like I like a year,
but I'm a number one top tour.
I'll tour with an owl cause that knows
nudie suits cost fucking five grand.
I feel like people are just finding out
about you.
I feel like this just,
this rise just started for you.
Well,
that's what happened.
Like I was saying,
when it debuted so high,
I went home and I was like,
that's crazy.
That debut until I,
then you get hungry,
you go home and you're like,
fuck him.
Even worse up their ass.
I'm going to go and a tour.
I'm going to do the video.
I'm going to go for it now.
Well,
people just,
I think a lot of people don't even know
about you yet.
I really do.
You know,
and hopefully this podcast and with some
other podcasts and all the youtube
videos and between the,
yeah,
you helping out and you know,
I appreciate it again,
coming on the show,
it had a fucking blast,
man.
My man,
it's fun shit.
And I love that you're a fan.
You know,
I love that there's places like this
where I can fucking talk about it.
I love that there was two,
I don't know even know how it happened.
I wish I could say that I planned this
whole thing out.
This is all total dumb luck.
Yeah.
You have anyone who I've,
anyone who happens upon my record,
if they find me,
I just,
I mean you gotta,
you know,
one of the biggest podcast in the world,
but even if just,
I've done interviews with people just
like,
I liked the record.
Will you be on my fucking podcast?
And we've got like 30 fucking live.
I'll do it.
If they're that big a fan,
I don't give a shit.
Oh that's cool.
Yeah.
Well that's going to change the,
once you run out of time,
fuck those folks can get too many beam.
It's going to be Joe Rogan only soon.
But uh,
there's a lot of other cool ones you've
got to do like Bert Kreischer and do as
many people as you can around town.
Yeah.
While I'm here and not playing
Coachella,
I may as well do the whole fucking
round.
It's hilarious.
At coachella.
Thought you were too risky.
Yeah,
I would love to see you up there.
You won't push.
You know,
I think it is kicking in.
I think part of it is,
it's like in the kind of,
I think it's cause it's country and it's
just so weird to hear.
And also when it's,
it's not as loud so that every,
all the bad words are so fucking clear
and you can hear it so well.
Like when you sync clip,
you can really hear it.
I just would love to see all those
fucking hipsters that are just going to,
the cool thing,
like people were like,
we're here for,
the cool thing was I was going to
Coachella.
But that's,
that's the whole fuck that's,
it's,
it's funny you brought that up.
No,
but seriously,
it's,
I'm glad you brought that up because
part of the point of this record to was
to piss off everybody.
I want it,
you know,
my redneck friends back home,
I wanted them to get pissed off by this.
I wanted the hipsters to get pissed off
by,
you know,
the,
like there's something to piss off
everybody.
Right.
So the goal was again,
talking about thinking no one's gonna
hear.
The goal was to fucking make sure nobody
bought it.
I did everything in my power to make
sure no one would listen to it.
And I think yes,
the key,
you know,
cause there's something to piss off
everyone on here.
What's this?
It's a hilarious idea.
The whole idea behind.
It's Hilarious,
but I think people get it
that it's re,
you know,
it's,
you can't make music like this.
That sounds like that.
If it's not coming from a real fucking
place,
you know,
I think,
yeah,
I'm going,
I,
and I think this,
this kind of stuff on,
I mean,
it's going to sound grander,
ridiculous,
but I think this ushers in the future,
because it's proving
people like a lot of stuff that you're
not going to get it from these
mainstream purveyors.
You're just not going to get it from the
not going to risk it.
They're not going to put the money out
for something like this because they
can't sell it to the radio stations.
They can't do what they normally do.
They don't have a place for it.
They don't know what it is.
So then you come along and you do it on
your own.
It takes off like a fucking wildfire and
that now they're scrambling.
Like you must be getting a lot of
mainstream music producer guys and
executives that are coming.
You trying to get in on this.
Oh,
totally.
And I tell,
you know what?
You always got to remember what the,
like we talking about,
don't give a fuck.
You got to keep that attitude.
Or you're going to fall down the fucking
drag you into the fucking the dental
staff.
This is going to be like,
and listen,
I like money.
We all like money,
but they're going to go,
hey,
if you tone down a little on the next
one,
we can get you on whatever.
You know,
we can get you on MTV or cnt or whatever
it is.
And then I'll go and then like,
you know,
that'll be 10 times the money and then
I'll think about it.
Don't get me wrong,
but I just got to stick with,
listen,
if I don't think they're wrong though,
they might.
It might be 10 times the money right
now.
But I think in the future this is going
to be giant.
I don't give a fucking shit if it
doesn't beat.
So that's good it because if I'm not
doing it the way I want it,
then I'll be miserable.
But because you are doing it the way you
want it,
it's fucking hilarious.
So like what,
what kind of people,
you don't have to name names,
but like what kind of people have come
up to you and tried to get in on this?
What kind of music?
Executive type characters
I'll say.
And I'm talking about country stars and
country exec in music executives.
I won't name names.
The biggest of the biggest and I,
I,
I'm not going to name names but I'm
talking about the biggest stars in
country have contacted me,
you know,
well a couple of different things that
I've heard through the grapevine cause I
don't,
I don't travel in those circles,
but some people who really love it,
some people,
some people are not untrue.
Joke have reached out to friends of mine
who know me making sure that I don't
shit on that because I talk shit about
everybody and they're like,
couldn't you tell him I'm cool because
it wasn't shit on me.
And a couple of people have come up with
some of the big boys and I'm and some
things that wouldn't even my name but
they don't want,
it's funny too cause I have some fans
who are literally the biggest country
stars on planet who won't
say that there until it becomes okay to
say it.
They're not saying it right.
They said it to my face.
I've literally met them and they've said
it to my face,
but they won't say it anywhere because
they don't want to lose their fucking
fans.
Like once it becomes,
if it becomes mainstream,
which I hope it doesn't,
but if it does maybe it will be cool.
You know what's mainstream though?
Who the fuck?
There's no mainstream anymore.
Mainstream used to be radio and
television.
Nobody gives a fuck.
So tonight show anymore.
Someone Dean on the tonight show for a
band.
Does that mean anything anymore?
They were,
they were talking to me about that,
you know,
because one thing you do is play late
night shows and they're like they ain't
going to have you.
I was like,
I don't give a fuck.
What did they mean?
Anything anymore now.
It used to be if you did like the
tonight show like you,
but then once it changed in like the
nineties like it started going away and
like the 90s and the two thousands they
were telling me that the numbers that
are even,
they're like,
you can't do obviously those big
talkers,
but they're saying you don't fucking,
those numbers don't.
It's like I'm moving the needle.
It's better than your podcasts going to
move to need a lot more than any fucking
talk show.
I guarantee you that.
That's bizarre.
Well,
you know,
I,
I don't get,
I hope I'm right,
but I think you're right.
I,
but I'm almost positive.
I heard it about books and other people
see positive.
I'm positive.
I'm right.
And I sterns play it a couple times,
you know,
like that shit so much bigger than doing
a fucking a tonight show or you know,
whatever those shows are,
which is enough.
I mind if I'm in town,
they want me to play,
I'll do it,
but they can't have me on.
So it doesn't matter.
They can't have you on.
And one of the problems with those shows
is like say you know,
no offense to any of these guys,
but say if Konan has someone on a show
that's a band,
I don't know how much input Konan has or
like maybe the tonight show,
Jimmy Fallon.
How much input does he have on what the
guests are?
I don't know.
I letterman I was told was the one who
really did like was like real country.
He was,
that was always the place where like
actual,
like Isabel played there,
you know like he would,
and Jason Isbell also is on an
independent label,
you know,
like it's hard for him to get on.
But with letterman given the approval,
you know,
he can get on it.
So some of those guys have like,
some people,
like Jay Leno was talking to me about
this,
like that he hated when he was doing the
tonight show and you'd have to have some
guy on from some TV show that he didn't
give a fuck about and he had to pretend
that we care.
You'd think he'd be in a position to
fucking wasn't.
He was doing the most mainstream shows.
But that's why is because it was so
mainstream.
He had to be like right down the middle
like non-offensive.
But now he's doing his own show.
He's doing that Jay Leno's garage.
If you ever seen that.
No.
Is it good?
You get to see what Jay was like.
Jay Leno's no weird on my TV for 20
years.
I don't know what he's like.
He's a great guy.
He was in here.
He did a podcast with us.
He was fucking here talking about the
doing a show for the mob and he was
talking about his mom heard about it.
Leno screamed you fucking Cock sucker.
It's,
it's bizarre like seeing him scream you
fucking cock sucker.
Like,
oh I remember hearing stories.
You know,
cause I obviously got,
some of my friends are musicians like
who they'll be playing a show and
they're like,
oh somebody canceled on the t is years
ago.
Cancel on the tonight show.
If you can get out to la.
He played tonight show,
you can do the show in whatever.
And they crunched the numbers and it
costs,
it's not moving in a band.
It's so expensive.
And they crunched the numbers and it's
like it wasn't worth their money to
play.
Like how fucking crazy is that?
That's correct.
And we become a band,
a small band,
and it's not worth the money to play.
The tonight show won't get enough return
on your money and far as far as they
were saying that it was 40 grand to play
cars with your paying the musicians,
a crew,
the trucks,
everything and driving all the way out
there.
It was,
it's like you're not going to make 40
grand in record sale.
So just stowing weird and the old days
like you were saying one play on that
and you're playing arenas.
Yeah,
I was talking to Paul Stanley about that
when he was in here.
It was real weird talking to him because
Paul Stanley of course was a huge
superstar in the 70s and it was all
record sales.
And as a matter of fact,
they couldn't get on the radio.
You know,
kiss had a really hard time being on the
radio.
They were sorta Kinda blackballed on the
outside.
Oh yeah.
But just because of the love from their
fans.
They stayed valid of course.
And they sell him fucking lunchboxes and
dolls and weird man.
I mean,
when I was a kid,
like a US kiss song on the radio,
like it was a moment to be excited.
Oh my God,
they're playing kiss.
Think dawn one they've ever played was
Beth,
which is weird because that was the drum
that was a big one.
But they pay Detroit rock city
occasionally,
you know,
or I want to rock and roll all night.
They play.
Yeah.
Down in Kentucky for a rock city.
I'd heard on the radio before and I
remember being blown away like,
Whoa,
I can't believe they're definitely not
taking seriously.
Yeah,
no,
they weren't taken seriously,
but there are fucking great rock and
roll band by the way.
That's a bit,
not the best fucking idea.
You put your kind of the biggest rock
pain ever and then you put the makeup
on.
Yeah,
go out and do whatever the fuck you
want.
Nobody knew who they were.
Yeah.
I met ace freely.
When I was like,
probably like before I was less than 10,
somewhere in that area.
Uh,
my uncle used to work for Howard marks
advertising,
which used to make all of this album
covers in New York City.
I'll know what yeah,
and my uncle vinny was an artist and so
he would him and uh,
this Guy Dennis that he worked with with
do these albums like destroyer,
I'll have to kill her car too.
Like some of the all time great ones.
They did kiss,
kiss double platinum.
They were really excited.
So I would get advanced copies of this
shit when I was a little kid.
I can't even imagine what getting an
advanced copy of record was when you're,
oh my God,
it wasn't something I would have known.
What an advance copy.
Like you probably look it up.
Yeah,
my uncle was involved with that.
And who's involved at a couple of other
ones?
Man.
Is that the name?
There's a name there only.
I don't know who the guy who did the
painting was my,
you know,
I think they hired someone to do the
painting,
but there what the advertising agency
would do was designed like the inside of
it,
like graphic design,
put all the photos and place and decide
how the font would look and all that
stuff.
It was really cool.
So when I was a kid that he would send
me these posters.
My mom just had them recently.
I beat these fucking,
when they had their solo albums,
you know,
they all have a individual hour.
I had the actual posters from the
fucking way.
Yeah.
I had each one.
I think each record was dedicated to the
other three.
Right.
Well I was,
it was it on the bag.
It's like dedicated to Paul a gene and
you know that's a creepy ass fucking
songs.
Yeah,
it was gene Simmons said to Christine 16
they came back around.
It became,
yeah,
you got to watch that shit.
Got To wash.
I said,
no,
you couldn't have a song about a 16 year
old that you have to fuck us and I've
got to have you.
I got an idea for us to,
what is it?
Don't say it.
No,
hold on dude.
Just take a take a breath and know what
you're going to say.
I taught,
taught me out of it.
No,
no,
no.
There was a couple of good songs off
from the soul albums back in the New
York group.
That was a good age.
Freely Song.
But that was from the silhouette.
Yeah.
Back in the New York group.
Unheralded Song.
Aces Solo record was the best of the
solid ones.
Yeah.
I don't remember him that well,
but I remember liking that one the best.
I'd have to go back and listen to them
again.
Remember they did a little disco and for
awhile like I was made for loving you.
They went disco people make fun.
I kinda like,
I mean looking back,
it was getting kinda good at the time
you hit song.
I love that song.
Yeah.
Ooh,
I want a disco shit.
That was so shitty.
You listen to me now.
It sounds,
everything in,
in looking back it was like,
now that music has gotten so shitty,
I mean bg sound fucking likely the best
band you ever heard.
Well that's what's interesting is I
think they were unjustly criticized.
Like if you listened to their style of
music,
um,
they had some really good songs.
The bgs had some interesting songs.
I can,
I can name,
you know,
but there's,
I can name you 20 killer bg songs and
that's another thing too.
You know,
it's important.
It sounds like you're,
you're with me.
Yeah.
Was Not all kinds of music.
I love all kinds of people that make the
shitty country that we were pointing out
before all they listened to his pop
country.
That's all I listen to the people.
I was reading an interview with prince
once and he was,
I don't remember exactly what he said,
but he's talking about how much you
loved
James Brown.
He in later in the interview he talks
about Joni Mitchell,
how much you love Joni Mitchell.
That's how you become prints,
right when you love James Brown and Joni
Mitchell.
Cause it's two completely different
things.
And then it comes out through prince as
something,
but if he only listened to James Brown,
it just sounded like a James Brown repo.
It's the other,
the folk music and the Weird Shit that
you listened to that made him such a
fucking kid.
Man.
I think music is a lot like everything
else.
Like I like variety and all kinds of
different foods.
I like variety and art and architecture
and I like variety and music.
It's interesting to hear like more than
a woman.
That is a good fucking song.
That bg song.
Good.
When you saw it in that movie,
Saturday night fever,
it's a great fun try not dance into
staying alive.
That's right.
That's what I'm talking about.
You know,
that's a good fucking song.
That era,
people were looking at that like,
okay,
we have this instead of led Zepplin.
This is what replaced the doors.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
And then you get older,
you realize that you can listen to both.
Kind of what happened to,
like I was talking about before with me
and he's like,
when you got into rock,
I was like,
wait a second.
Leyland and John Lennon aren't that
fucking far apart.
They're much closer together than like,
you know what's playing on the radio
right now.
Yeah.
That's,
I mean waylon used to play with buddy
holly.
That's all you got to start.
No Shit.
Yeah,
he started,
I mean it's the most famous story of
all,
but he had,
he's supposed to be on that plane.
Dwight Yoakam was probably the first guy
that was a real country guy that I was a
fan of.
I was a fan of Dwight.
He kinda crossed over a little bit.
You want to happen.
He's a Kentucky boy as well.
A lot of great music from Kentucky.
Huh.
But he,
I always thought of him as the Kentucky
Guy and he is,
but he actually had to move to la to
make it.
He had,
he was in the punk scene out here cause
back then like wearing a dressing like
that,
wearing the cowboy hat and plan kind of
old style buck owens country was thought
of as crazy as it.
I mean,
he wasn't playing,
you know,
punk music,
but he was an,
he was kind of an out right outside or
up,
you know,
and that was thought of as like a weird
thing to be doing.
He'd seemed to me that what he was doing
was like an Ode to the classics,
you know,
it's like he was a [inaudible].
He also put his own spin on it.
200% a hundred percent but you like it
reminiscent of like really great country
music of old.
Like he was obviously a,
he was a huge fan of that music and
yeah,
I felt like he was one of the first guys
who
brought that old sound back but kind of
got some,
you know,
got air play it,
he got a lot of airplay and mainstream
with going back to the old guys.
Yeah.
Like that ain't that lonely yet.
Song,
that song play guitars,
cadillacs and hillbilly music that's
done that.
It was a huge hit.
That was inspiration to subtract two
beer.
We'd coutures and Honky tonk music,
but he was like a God that you were
allowed to.
Like,
it's like you're allowed to like him as
a country person.
It made you like the 90,
like you were talking about.
Shit changes so fast.
Even the fucking like you look back at
mainstream country in the 90s,
it sounds like fucking raw deal
recordings compared to what we got out
there right now.
I'd like it's changed so much.
So fast.
That like next sheet like this,
the kind of what mainstream Alan
Jackson,
Randy Travis.
That shit sounds like fucking like down
in the dirt.
Like it sounds like blue,
like a gritty.
Yeah,
it sounds like I'm fucking jug band.
What has happened?
We've like,
could you imagine if Johnny Cash could
watch those guys?
Like throwing their fucking hands,
those hip hop hand signs,
the perfectly quaffed outfits and then
jeans with rips already and um,
people always send me these genes.
Repin or did you buy them?
No,
this is ripped.
Yeah.
No,
that's real.
Yeah,
I swear I wasn't going to wear it.
I'm not paid a hundred for that.
Um,
now people send me memes all the time of
that shit.
That's what it's called.
So they,
they put like,
yeah,
they'll help picture of wayland.
It's a place,
I don't know what it's called.
It's like I've gotten a hundred of these
but make sure why.
And I'm like Florida,
Georgia line.
Yeah.
I think I pissed there at once and I've
gotten that meme.
I've gotten a hundred of you find that.
But there's a hundred of those guys like
you know,
rolling in there.
People love making those cause there's,
yeah,
there's an audience for that still,
which is great.
Well shooter talked about,
he had that song,
they should outlaw you.
That was specifically about that.
Like these fake country guys like these
especially fake out log eyes.
Yeah.
But what his dad had to go through to
make it in country whose dad was a,
I mean a real pioneer in a,
a,
a rebel in a lot of ways.
Like he did whatever the fuck you wanted
to do and it worked and that sound
became like super popular.
And Wayne Lake Jennings,
you listen to a loyal and records.
Now the best shit,
it sounds like it was quarter.
Yes.
It's amazing.
It sounds,
it has an age to fucking day and sun and
shooters.
Weird too man,
because he does all kinds of strange
music album is a coon tosh.
It's like almost electronic and it's
fucking killer.
It's killer.
Well he's,
he's another guy that just wherever his
fucking,
what am I fit back?
One of my favorite guys,
it's got billy Joe Shaver is like Sam,
he's old now and he wrote a lot of this.
There's a way on an album called Honky
tonk here.
I was at Bailey.
Joe Shaver wrote every song,
it's my favorite way on record and billy
joe is still around.
He just put out a new album last year
and it's fucking great.
And um,
the first song to duet with Willie
Nelson and it's called hard to be an
outlaw in the song,
is hard to be an outlaw when you ain't
want it anymore.
So Tim,
who was actually part of that law
movement,
which I'm not,
I'm not part of that,
you know,
I'm,
I'm just here,
have,
you know,
doing what I do.
What is the outlaw movement?
That was the 70s when they were the
equivalent of,
you know,
I don't know.
You know,
but you're kind of comedy,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
what do you mean?
It's not even that funny,
but like people listen,
I've just,
I'm just singing like I see it,
you know,
fighting fucking fart.
So you know,
but it's,
there's something,
there's,
it's funny,
I'm laughing.
Yeah.
Right.
People are laughing at,
so I don't get mad when people,
but it is very outlaw and a lot of ways
by the method of going about putting it
out.
But I'll to defend them,
like you don't want to claim it because
it's like an iconic name,
like outlaw country,
like those guys.
But those guys were,
that was when pop,
well that was when country music,
which by the way,
that country on the radio then sound
like I said,
sounds great now,
but it was a lot of strings and got
really lush.
And then people like Waylon Willie moved
out in Nashville,
moved to Austin,
started smoking weed and said,
I'm going to do it my fucking way.
And it's,
and that's what kind of,
you know,
that kind of thing and owns like,
get the fucking strings out,
get all this shit out.
I just want to play Mi,
guitar,
Bass,
drums,
you know,
just back to the basics.
So they were really pushing the
envelope,
you know,
way more than anything I've ever
Nashville have any,
I mean,
how much of Nashville like real music
and how much of Nashville is like pop,
you know?
Um,
or when you're there,
it's really,
it's so funny because like I said,
most of my family's from Nashville,
so I went there all the time growing up
and it was really almost,
not a ghost town,
but it was just like,
it was a kind of,
had a small town feel and you would,
but you would see crystal gayle or
whoever it was on the streets,
but has known it was senator of country
music,
but it was,
it was not
a flashy town.
And now it's the place.
It's,
it's another Hollywood.
It's what you should go.
It change.
But it's real recent,
right?
It's within the last I went,
there's a,
this the new,
the silver lake,
which is apparently the hip plays here.
The silver lake in Nashville is like
call his eachnet East Nashville and I
don't think,
I didn't even ever been there as a kid.
I didn't,
I don't think it was just slumps and now
it's,
you can get a place there.
It's till fucking expensive.
So it's got gentrified told like how
many years ago this happened.
If you bought a house there five years
ago,
you're fucking swimming in it right now.
Yeah,
because I started going to xannies in
Nashville's a comedy club.
I started going there.
I just want to say like maybe 10 years
ago I started going there,
maybe 10 bet it's weight.
It was way different,
way different.
I mean these places now,
like they have those spotlights that
stream the sky and they'll have like
some fucking grand opening thing or some
press release thing and you'll see like
these tour buses and Papa razzies and
like what is going on.
That's another thing too is when I was a
kid,
you know my,
I had family who was friends with
country,
not could they were in the business to
just,
if you're in town,
that's what a lot of people do.
You know con ever,
never.
No punk and Paparazzi.
Now I have people I know people there,
you know when you bought,
when you,
you got to like warn people where you're
going and do this and that's why I'm
hoping it's people like Jason or sturge
we'll kind of turn people start moving
there for the right fucking,
you know,
make the right kind of music.
But still it's gotta be some that are
doing that.
Right.
There are some,
but I mean how many of them are these
fucking coughed up bands or the hair
gel?
Almost all.
I mean like all chains.
Yeah,
I mean,
but you hear it.
How many sturgis could hear it come into
your podcast?
You know,
sturgill is a rare dude.
He's a rare as a shooter there.
They're rare guys,
but we're really name it.
There's,
listen,
there's way more of it than you think.
But those Jason is bells and Sturgis
falls.
[inaudible] don't like a guy like that.
When when sturge we'll puts out a CD and
then people find out about it and people
aspire and then they,
they want to be like that.
And then it sort of gives birth to more
people like that or more people who can
express themselves.
But what it didn't ever,
it's almost like Nirvana.
You know,
remember when they came out it's like,
oh fuck,
fuck the old shit.
It's time for real rock and roll the
tape back.
Poison.
Yeah,
exactly.
But all that it ended up doing was
bringing out a bunch of Shitty Nirvana,
copycats.
There was a lot of that,
there was a lot of that.
And there's going to be a lot of
surgical copycats coming out soon and
they're not going to,
they're going to be doing it because
they think it's going to sell.
Not because sturgill did it cause he
want,
he had something on his mind that he
wanted to sing.
You know,
it's gonna come out the wrong way.
So well,
there's,
there's always going to be the guy that
pretends to be the guy that you love.
Yeah.
You know,
like there's the gun that was good.
I want you to sell the records,
so I'm times or the host,
the TV shows or do movies or,
you know,
whatever.
Those are the guys.
Like you let go.
This guy's sort of inauthentic,
like something's going on.
But,
but when,
when someone is authentic though,
you could tell,
right?
Can't you tell like storage is,
you could fucking tell,
listen to that new a sailors guide to
Earth.
Come on,
man.
It's the best record of the year by far
fucking since that,
with mine,
right in front of me.
It's sensational.
It's so good.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's,
it's weird how it all flows together
too.
It's like,
Ooh,
that's a magnum opus magnus,
you know,
no one would go into a studio,
make a record like that,
hoping,
you know,
thinking that's going to now sell it.
He did it because he wanted to make,
and you got to eat.
He's got to have,
it's very rare that you're gonna have a
big company that sells records that has
the wherewithal to let it go like that.
Go just go do whatever you want,
man.
I think he did it all day.
I think you produced it himself and did
everything.
I think he did it all themselves.
You know honey,
honey,
he did.
He did.
He know.
It's funny,
my first ever La Gig,
the gut,
I produced my record,
the band after he produced the banner
came in right after I left was honey
honey and uh,
they heard my record in the studio and
they're like,
next time you're in La while you open a
shell.
And I'm like,
yeah,
sure.
So I played a few songs with them,
acoustic,
they came out in costume and backed me
up for a couple of songs cause they had
the record but it wasn't out yet.
So that was my,
that was my first la show ever.
It was a,
wow.
That's crazy.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Your friend.
You're,
you're real good friends.
We've done a bunch of shows together.
Oh,
no way.
Yeah,
no,
it's funny.
That was my first fucking la show with
honey,
honey.
Yeah,
they did new year's with me last year.
Oh,
no way.
At the wiltern in La.
How big that is.
That's big.
Thousand people was crazy.
Yeah,
it was Joey Diaz.
Honey honey.
His last album was fucking great.
Ren Dunkin.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
They were amazing.
They're really good man.
And he does it.
What does this,
that's them.
That's them backing me at honey.
Honey engaging.
They have a,
she has a beard on.
Yeah.
I think that that was,
that was,
that was a sign of things to come when
people want to dress up in costume,
when they're backing me,
when they're on station,
they don't want to be seen.
I think I should've seen that as a,
as a possible sign that maybe I was
doing.
It was a little bit out there.
Well,
what I was going to say about them was
they have this song,
um,
and I used a part of the song on my,
the music for it with my comedy central
special,
the opening music.
That's all from them.
That's how I know her music.
And it's a song called punk kid and they
can't put it out because they made it,
they spent all their own money making
it,
but the record company wanted it.
And so like when the record company
hired them to do a song or do a,
an album,
they wanted the punk kid song and they
wanted it for free and they're like,
no,
but we spent all this money on that
song.
This is our song.
We wrote it.
You can't own this.
Like you can't,
you can't gain the song.
When they tried to and they said no.
So that song,
it's like it's out in the ether.
So you have to figure out what to do
with that song that's going to hold onto
it for awhile.
I will say I did learn,
you know,
being around the music as much in the
head.
I knew I'd heard all those stories.
That's crazy.
That's why I bought my mat,
my master's degree.
You can't do fucking,
you can't touch this.
They don't.
You don't need them anymore.
If I'm quoting the hammer,
you know you don't need them anymore.
I don't like what we're talking about
about distribution.
You'll get more distribution from doing
this show or more people here.
We're going to find this.
See,
guarantee you.
It's going to be crazy and from doing
mine and do Adam Carolla's and do
everybody else's corolla played at the
other day.
Maybe you're too,
we'd all,
these guys will do it.
You can get on Joey Diaz.
Joe,
you'll have yawned Arielle have you on
Dunkin.
Anybody who was around,
we'll have you on and people hear about
it.
This is the new,
it's a new time man.
It's a new world and you know they're
not trying to,
you know it's,
I'm just happy it came,
you know,
then I'm here now because like you said
20 years ago,
this album would not exist.
It would not exist,
but it exists.
Wheeler Walker redneck shit.
Go get it.
Yeah.
I also,
I think it was someone said it was the
first album to chart on the bill country
billboard charts with a bad word.
Really nobody,
no country charts it cause ever charged
with a bad word in the title Redneck
Shit.
Eat and pussy kicking ass.
That's one of my favorite songs,
dude.
I'm telling you,
I'm not gonna lie.
I puts a smile on my face.
I'll be listening to this at the gym.
By the way,
there's a download code in that too.
Oh,
there is?
you guys are the vinyl.
You get a download code.
Dude,
I want to pay.
I want to buy it on itunes.
Well,
this guy,
you want to see it too?
Yeah.
He's going to fucking make him by giving
him he's been,
he must it cost nine bucks.
That's what normal.
That's a normal album.
Costs right on.
I can use nine bucks.
That's good.
Whatever the normal.
I didn't sturge we'll had the number one
song and the number one album last week.
Yeah,
I think his album's a loom and that
number one,
keep him on until he spent half his time
fucking taking motherfuckers out.
I don't know if that's true.
I really don't think he's an assassin.
I think,
um,
you should go to a doctor.
I'm telling you.
Look just like Ben Hoffman too.
It's so weird.
Well,
I,
like I said,
someone said,
I look like exact and that I don't,
that person's an asshole.
That doesn't make any sense at all.
But I don't want you both handsome,
but that's ridiculous.
It's just a beard thing I guess.
But,
well,
I would say someone say you look like
Zach Galifianakis you have different
color.
People just saw beard.
People are stupid.
Right?
People see me doing this shit in there
just like he can't be real.
So they're like,
he's got to be somebody.
Oh,
that's it.
And then also that video of you at the
fake mustache that hurt things.
Yeah.
It doesn't help but whatever.
Fucking listen,
they can't take a joke.
Regular Walker Jr com you fucks.
And uh,
go to itunes.
Go pick this up.
Thank you sir.
That was awesome having me.
That was good,
man.
It's a lot of fun.
I hope you had fun cause I did eating
Pussy and kicking ass folks.
We see tomorrow.
Wow.
Yeah.